Hosting provided by HostTornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 32, OpenSCAD. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. Yeah, I've been answering a lot of questions on stack overflow and quora this is this is my new my new hobby not answering questions for your
由HostTornado提供主机服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第32集，OpenSCAD。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。是的，我最近在Stack Overflow和Quora上回答了很多问题，这是我新的爱好，不是为了回答你们的
child yet no no definitely you know so you know he he's like why is the sky blue and i tell him to ask me on stack overflow i need i need more points yeah yeah ask me on Stack Overflow. I need more points. Yeah, yeah. Ask me on Sky Exchange. But yeah, I've been answering questions on like Math Stack Exchange and Stack Overflow and Quora. And it's been interesting. It's kind of fun.
孩子，还没呢，绝对不是。你知道，他会问“为什么天空是蓝色的”，我就告诉他去Stack Overflow上问我，我需要更多积分。是的，是的，在Stack Overflow上问我。我需要更多积分。是的，是的。在Stack Exchange上问我。但确实，我一直在Math Stack Exchange、Stack Overflow和Quora上回答问题。这很有趣，也挺好玩的。
One thing I noticed is, you know, I've met people who have, you know, a bazillion points in stack overflow. And I realized that at a certain level, it becomes almost like a click. Um, it's kind of weird. Like, you know, I was asking people, how do you get so many points? And I guess at some level people start, like you can, you can basically invest your points and questions and so the questions that are really really hard to answer or or that are say like very nebulous you know a bunch of people with a lot of points will answer and someone will pick one of them and that person
我注意到的一件事是，我遇到过在Stack Overflow上有无数积分的人。我意识到在一定水平上，这几乎变成了一个小圈子。嗯，这有点奇怪。就像我问别人，你是怎么得到这么多积分的？我想在某种程度上，人们开始，你可以基本上把你的积分投资在问题上，所以那些非常非常难回答的问题，或者说非常模糊的问题，一群有很多积分的人会去回答，然后有人会选出其中一个，那个人
get even more points and so it becomes like you kind of have to know the right people and and i realize like almost everything when you get to a high enough level devolves into a click like for example I worked with a guy on my last team who was the world junior chess champion and you know he was like a grandmaster
会得到更多的积分，所以这变得有点像你必须认识对的人。我意识到，当你达到足够高的水平时，几乎所有事情都会演变成一个小圈子。例如，我上一家公司的同事，他是世界青少年国际象棋冠军，你知道，他是一位特级大师，
and he had a huge you know chess rating I don't know what it was but it was probably like I don't even know what the ratings range are but it was you know obviously one of the top in the world it's probably not as good as mine oh yeah yeah i'm sure we could we i'm sure we could write our computer program to beat him but that's beside the point he uh and he was basically saying it's kind of like a click you know you have to go to the right tournaments you have to socialize with the right people so you get invited see that's part of it is you have to get invited to the tournaments so that you can get the rating so you can be the best now like theoretically if you won every single game like a tournament you know
他有很高的国际象棋等级分，我不知道具体是多少，但可能，我甚至不知道等级分的范围，但显然是世界顶尖水平之一。可能没我厉害。哦，是的，我肯定我们可以写个电脑程序打败他，但那不是重点。他基本上说这就像一个小圈子，你必须去参加正确的比赛，你必须和对的人社交，这样你才能被邀请。看，这就是其中的一部分，你必须被邀请参加比赛，这样你才能获得等级分，这样你才能成为最强。现在，理论上如果你赢了每一场比赛，比如一场锦标赛，你知道，
if you beat everybody who you ever faced then theoretically you know the next highest person should feel rather compelled to play you right but but in practice like it just doesn't work that way that a lot of it comes down to sort of networking and meeting the right people and all that and i realized that like even on the internet things like quora and stack exchange actually work the same way when you get to a certain level but that's what i always say about the movie industry right like that you know people want to be actors or actresses and there's like the lightning striking chance that you will be found but that for the most part it's about knowing people and having an in and getting the roles and then people want to take like a safe bet so like they want to take you because for a small movie role because
如果你打败了你面对的每一个人，那么理论上，下一个最高分的人应该感到有义务和你比赛，对吧？但在实践中，它根本不是那样运作的。很大程度上归结于社交和结识对的人等等。我意识到，即使在互联网上，像Quora和Stack Exchange这样的东西，当你达到一定水平时，实际上也是以同样的方式运作的。但我总是这样评价电影行业，人们想成为演员或女演员，有那种像闪电击中般的几率被发现，但大部分情况下，这关乎于认识人，有门路，获得角色。然后人们想采取稳妥的策略，所以他们想选你，因为对于一个小电影角色，
you were in a commercial and they want to take you for a big movie role because you were in a commercial and they want to take you for a big movie role because you were in a medium movie role right and so like exactly you have to start somewhere but like if you start at the bottom it takes a long time to get to the top yeah exactly and i mean this idea that like doing the thing that that that they're trying to evaluate whether it's chess or answering questions or whatever like it's not sufficient you know like you could as i was saying you could just beat absolutely everybody in chess and never become the world champion just because you wouldn't have access to the people who would get you the the higher rating and and i feel like most systems in the world most social systems work this way and and that realizing that that is even true on
因为你拍过广告，他们想选你演大电影角色，因为你拍过广告，他们想选你演大电影角色，因为你演过中等电影角色，对吧？所以，确实，你必须从某个地方开始，但如果你从底层开始，要到达顶峰需要很长时间。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，这种观点，即做他们试图评估的事情，无论是国际象棋还是回答问题，这都不够。你知道，正如我所说的，你可以打败国际象棋里的每一个人，却永远无法成为世界冠军，仅仅因为你无法接触到那些能让你获得更高等级分的人。我觉得世界上大多数系统，大多数社会系统都是这样运作的，意识到这一点即使在
the internet was just fascinating interesting so do you go for quantity of questions like you just go on there and like answer questions that are too dumb that nobody else wants to answer them or do you like go for like the really thoughtful like oh this is interesting it makes me happy to answer this question yeah so um i realized the you know i i would answer anything just about i mean i would answer the dumb question but the volume of people who are there to answer dumb questions is so large that i never get the opportunity you know like like i'm just not checking it often enough or even if i do I can just tell like if someone answer if someone asks you know why is my homework assignment code not working and there's a divide by zero
互联网上也是如此，真是太迷人了。那么，你是追求问题的数量吗？比如你只是上去回答那些太蠢、没人想回答的问题，还是你追求那种非常深思熟虑的，比如“哦，这很有趣，回答这个问题让我很高兴”？是的，所以我意识到，我几乎什么都会回答。我的意思是，我会回答愚蠢的问题，但那里回答愚蠢问题的人数太多了，以至于我从来没有机会。你知道，我只是没有足够频繁地查看它，或者即使我查看了，我也能看出来，如果有人问“为什么我的家庭作业代码不工作”，而且有一个除以零的错误，
like by the time I like I'm usually on my phone I'm usually traveling you know by the time I get to a place where I can answer the question um someone like 10 other people have already answered it you know so I'm sort of forced into answering the deeper questions which is kind of is is more fun anyways right um so one of those questions sounds an awful lot like work maybe yeah i'm not gonna lie like i'm glad that you help society well you know actually the reason why i do it isn't to help society, but it's because maybe this is connected to why I answer the harder questions is that I want to provoke a discussion with people who think I'm wrong. Either that or I want to know I'm right about something that's like pretty nebulous. So, for example, I answered this question on Quora and it was effectively like, how do I start a machine learning startup? The question was, this guy said, uh, I was given the lead machine learning engineer at a startup, but I'm basically never, I'm relatively new to machine learning. Oh no.
等我能回答问题的时候，我通常在手机上，通常在旅行中，你知道，等我到了能回答问题的地方，已经有10个人回答了。所以我被迫去回答更深奥的问题，这反正更有趣，对吧？嗯，其中一个问题听起来很像工作。也许吧，我不撒谎，我很高兴你帮助了社会。嗯，你知道，其实我做这件事的原因不是为了帮助社会，而是因为，也许这和我回答更难的问题有关，我想激起那些认为我错了的人的讨论。要么就是我想确认我在某些非常模糊的事情上是对的。例如，我在Quora上回答了这个问题，它实际上是“我该如何创办一家机器学习初创公司？”这个问题是，这个人说，我被任命为一家初创公司的首席机器学习工程师，但我对机器学习相对陌生。哦，不。
Yeah. Yeah. But then he qualifies it by saying I have practice in software engineering from industry. Wait, so hold on. So I think I've seen this in a movie before person gets a job for a role like financial analyst and then the first thing they do is they google what does a financial analyst do yeah exactly so uh i wish you would say the startup so i'd know uh not to join us but okay but sorry So he has software engineering experience, but now he's lead machine learning director, VP. Yeah, exactly. He's CMLO at some company. It sounds like a rapper. Yeah, CLO was a rapper, right?
是的。是的。但他通过说“我在行业中有软件工程实践经验”来限定它。等等，等一下。我想我以前在电影里见过这个，一个人得到了一份像财务分析师这样的工作，然后他们做的第一件事就是去谷歌搜索“财务分析师是做什么的”。是的，完全正确。所以我希望他说出那家初创公司的名字，这样我就知道不要加入它了。但好吧，抱歉。所以他有软件工程经验，但现在他是首席机器学习总监、副总裁。是的，完全正确。他是某家公司的CMLO。听起来像个说唱歌手。是的，CLO是个说唱歌手，对吧？
Anyways, so I answered the question as best I could and basically told him, he wouldn't give any details on what machine learning he's doing, just that he's doing machine learning. And so I posted a link. The sentient kind. Yeah, exactly. I'm on this startup called Skynet. And so, you know, I tried to answer as best I could. I'll post a link to it in the show notes.
总之，我尽我所能回答了这个问题，基本上告诉他，他没有提供任何关于他在做什么机器学习的细节，只是说他在做机器学习。所以我贴了一个链接。那种有知觉的。是的，完全正确。我正在做这个叫Skynet的初创公司。所以，你知道，我尽力回答了。我会把链接贴在节目笔记里。
Did your answer involve Newton's laws of robotics? No, but I did tell him to always... You didn't answer it right. Always include if created Skynet fitness minus 999 just to make sure that his genetic algorithm knows it's been punished if it creates Skynet. But it's fun. People can vote on your question.
你的回答涉及牛顿机器人定律了吗？没有，但我确实告诉他要总是……你没答对。总是包含“如果创建了Skynet，适应度减999”，以确保他的遗传算法知道如果它创建了Skynet就会受到惩罚。但这很有趣。人们可以给你的问题投票。
The other thing is there's really interesting in-depth answers to more of these meta questions like, you know, what library should I use to do X? There might be five choices. And people who wrote those
另一件事是，对于更多这类元问题，有非常深入的回答，比如“我应该用什么库来做X？”可能有五个选择。而那些编写了这些
libraries answer it's kind of cool and then they start a debate so i always wonder that like i see i see posts on like hacker news or um other places and it's like hi i'm the author of this or i'm the guy who this page is about like if they didn't post it themselves and then they say stuff and i'm always wondering like i guess i view it slightly different than like a blog post author like giving like oh thank you for the i misspelled the word i'm fixing it about people like defending or re-explaining like i guess it's good like it helps improve the thing like often they'll go edit the page to be more clear or whatever but other times like they just get involved in an argument and it's kind of like i don't know like if i did it i think i'd kind of just like do it and leave it out there like i kind of don't want to i might read the responses but i don't want to like or if you answered a question on quora yeah so like
库的人会回答，这很酷，然后他们就开始辩论。所以我总是好奇，我在Hacker News或其他地方看到帖子，上面写着“嗨，我是这个的作者”或者“我是这个页面所说的那个人”，如果他们不是自己发的，然后他们说了一些话，我总是想，我想我对此的看法与博客文章作者略有不同，比如“哦，谢谢你，我拼错了单词，我正在修改它”。关于人们辩护或重新解释，我想这很好，它有助于改进事物。通常他们会去编辑页面使其更清晰等等，但其他时候，他们只是卷入了一场争论，这有点像，我不知道，如果是我，我想我会直接做完就放在那里，我可能不会读回复，或者如果我在Quora上回答了一个问题，是的，所以
answering a question on quora would be fine but like i wouldn't want to like people like getting into my question or like getting into a debate about it like oh i see what you're saying that would be like not offensive but just like i feel like i waste my time or like ah you missed the point and like trying to put more work into it and yeah well this is you know like this is why the kind of people who who who enjoy that are the people who invent programming languages we talked about this one time like you know you think about like it's never occurred at least not to me to invent to make a new programming language and we've seen plenty of languages come and go
在Quora上回答问题没问题，但我不想让人们卷入我的问题，或者卷入关于它的辩论。比如“哦，我明白你的意思了”，那不会让人反感，只是觉得我在浪费时间，或者“啊，你没抓住重点”，然后试图投入更多工作。是的，嗯，这就是为什么那些喜欢这样的人是发明编程语言的人。我们有一次谈到这个，你知道，你认为，至少对我来说，从来没想过要发明一种新的编程语言，我们已经看到很多语言来来去去，
through our lifetime so it's not like all the good ones were taken or anything like that but uh you know i wondered why like why is it that we've never tried to invent a language i think what it comes down to is i don't care enough like like most languages do what i want and there's already plenty of them out there we've we can talk about languages for shows forever but like there's enough tools i can always get a job done somehow. And the kind of person who cannot deal with the tool set as it is and needs another tool, that's also the kind of person who would fight to the death on Quora or Hacker News or whatever
在我们的一生中，所以并不是所有好的都被占用了。但我好奇为什么我们从来没试过发明一种语言。我想归根结底是我不在乎，大多数语言都能做我想做的事，而且外面已经有很多了。我们可以永远谈论语言，但工具足够多，我总能以某种方式完成工作。而那种无法处理现有工具集、需要另一种工具的人，也是那种会在Quora或Hacker News上为了捍卫他们的库或工具而战斗到底的人。这些品质必须是联系在一起的，对吧？是的。所以小心点。我正在Quora上回答问题。我正在Quora上回答问题。我现在可能会去发明一种语言。所以我现在正在发一个问题。
to defend their library or their tool or what have you. Those qualities have to be tied together, right? Yeah. So watch out. I'm answering questions on Quora. I'm answering questions on Quora. I might go invent a language now. So I'm posting a question right now.
Programming Throwdown第33集应该关于什么？我该说什么？有人能给我写个脚本吗？你觉得那个问题会有人回答吗？嗯，你会得到一些答案。我想听众中的一些人会告诉你该去哪。等等，什么？哦，天哪。所以我们上集谈到了编程面试。我想是上一集。没错。
What should programming throwdown episode 33 be about? And what should I say? Could someone write me a script please do you think that question would be answered um yeah you'd get some answers i think some people from the audience would tell you where to go wait what uh oh man so we talked last episode we talked about, uh, programming interviews. I think it was last. That's right.
确实。而且，就在那之后，我把它写下来了。你在某处面试了。我写道，我不能透露该信息。好吧。如果我透露了，我会为那个人感到非常难过。嗯，正如我所知。嗯，所以我在那之后立刻遇到了这个，我把它写
It was. And, uh, I, right after that, actually, and I wrote it down. You interviewed somewhere. I wrote, I can't disclose that information. Okay. If I had, I would feel really bad for that person. Um, as I always know. Um, so I came across this right afterwards and I like wrote it
下来了，因为这会很有用，我会在下一集记住它。嗯，但有一篇文章，我对这个网站一无所知。我想我应该读一下，看看这个网站本身是否好。我确实读了那篇文章，但它说，这是为你的面试选择一种编程语言。所以如果你要进行编程面试，你如何选择一种语言？网站是codingforinterviews.com。我不知道它是关于什么的，但这篇文章
down because like, this is going to be good and I'm going to remember it for the next episode. Um, but there was an article, I don't know anything about this site. I guess I should have read it and seen if the site itself is any good. I did read the article, but it says, uh, it's choosing a programming language to do your interview. So if you're going to do a programming interview, how do you choose a language? And the website is coding for interviews.com. I have have no idea what it's about anyways but the article is
很有趣，基本上说你应该考虑什么，他们有一些很好的观点，比如你应该查一下你面试的公司是否有强烈的偏好，他们展示了Facebook、Google、Amazon、Microsoft的强烈偏好等等。然后一旦你做了这些，你应该练习，然后是一些非常常见的事情。他们这里有一些很好的东西，我以前没想过，比如抛出异常，人们在那种语言中抛出异常吗？人们通常怎么做？关于类型转换，在选择的语言中要小心如何来回转换。然后他们有一个有趣的观点，对它有一些看法。
interesting and basically says like what should you think about and you know they had some good points which is like you should look up if your company has a strong preference the one you're interviewing with and they show like facebook google amazon microsoft here's the like strong preferences or whatever um and then once you do that you should practice and then no common like very common things um and and they have some good stuff in here that i wouldn't have always thought about like throwing exceptions it's like do people throw exceptions in that language and like what is kind of like the way people do it or don't um And about casting, like being careful about how to cast back and forth between stuff in the language you choose. And then they have an interesting point, have some opinions about it.
比如你喜欢它的什么？你不喜欢它的什么？我几乎在每次面试中都遇到过这个问题。至少有一次，有人问我“你为什么喜欢那种语言？”或者“你最不喜欢的是什么？”等等。基本上是想让你充满热情。我不知道作为一个面试官，这是一个多好的问题，
Like what do you like about it? What do you don't like about it? And I've actually had that in every interview pretty much I've ever done. At least at one point, somebody asked me like, why do you like that language? Or what's the thing you dislike most or whatever? Basically wanting you to be passionate. And I don't know as, like, an interviewer, like, how good of a question that is
因为我认为人们使用一种语言而不深入思考它是完全没问题的。我不知道这对我来说是否说明了他们作为一个人的什么，他们没有深入思考语言的缺陷。我不知道这对我来说是否说明了他们作为一个人的什么，他们没有深入思考语言的缺陷。是的，我认为这是一个有很多好答案的问题。如果有人说“不，我真的很喜欢Java，因为它有静态类型，我被坑过很多次”等等，
because I think it's perfectly fine for people to, like, have been using a language and not think deeply about the language. And I don't know that, for me, that says anything about them as a person, that, like, they didn't think deeply about the flaws of I don't know that for me that says anything about them as a person that like they didn't think deeply about the flaws of the language they're in yeah I think it's the kind of question that like has many good answers you know if someone was to say no I really love Java because it has like static typing and I've been burned so many times or whatever like
有一个深刻的答案，那会很好。如果有人说“我只想使用最适合工作的工具”，并以这种方式去做，那也很好。我的意思是……好吧。这是一个困难的……但你是对的，它不是……
has a like some insightful answer that'd be good. And if somebody said, I just want to use, like, whatever tool is best for the job and kind of went about it that way, it's fine, too. I mean... Okay. It's a difficult... But, yeah, you're right that it's not...
它绝对不应该成为你判断的依据，比如“这家伙对Java真的很热情，伙计们。让我们雇佣他”，你知道吗？是的。除非你在制造编程语言，或者真的很深入地在制造编程语言，或者真的很深入地在为语言制造工具之类的，我想是的，那是真的。但，是的，不，
It definitely shouldn't, you know, be the thing that you go off of, like, this guy is really passionate about Java, guys. Let's hire him, you know? Yeah. Unless you were making programming languages or, like, really deep down were making programming languages or like really deep down making tools for languages or something i guess yeah that's true that's but but yeah no
你有一个很好的观点。如果有人只是说，没有错误的答案，你只是在寻找一个可以进行的对话，或者其他什么。是的，完全正确。是的，我最近确实被问到了，比如“我是多大的语言迷？”这就是有人问我的。真的吗？我会和其他团队成员辩论吗？这是一次面试吗？是的。而且，
you have a good point i like if somebody's just like there isn't a bad answer you're just looking for a conversation to have or whatever yeah exactly exactly yeah i did get asked it recently like what it like how big of a language buff am I? That's what somebody asked me or whatever. Really? Would I get in a debate with other team members? Was this an interview or something? Yeah. And,
我只是说，嗯，好吧。我尽量保持中立。我关心我在做什么，但我不想为了争论而争论。是的，
uh, I was just like, uh, okay. Like I try to be middle of the road. Like I care about what I'm doing, but I don't want to get in arguments for the sake of arguing. Yeah,
绝对。这可能是真的，也可能不是，但实际上如果你仔细想想，这是一个非常可怕的问题，因为除非你很了解那个人，“你最大的缺点是什么？”是的，这是一个非常糟糕的问题，因为每个人都想说一些实际上是好的东西。“我是个完美主义者”，对吧？是的，完全正确。我工作太努力了。是的，我工作太努力了。是的，是的，就像这些事情。而且因为每个人都想说一些实际上是好的东西。“我是个完美主义者”，对吧？是的，完全正确。我工作太努力了。是的，我工作太努力了。
definitely. Which may or may not be true but actually that's if you think about it that's a pretty terrifying question to be asked because unless you know the person pretty well what's your biggest flaw yeah it's like it's such a bad question because everybody wants to say something that's actually good i'm a perfectionist right like yeah exactly i i work too hard yeah i work too hard yeah yeah it's like these things and Because everybody wants to say something that's actually good. I'm a perfectionist, right? Yeah, exactly. I work too hard. Yeah, I work too hard.
是的，是的。就像这些事情。他们以为自己在说“哈哈，我把它变成了一个积极的方面”。但如果你真的承认一些深层的缺陷，我不知道。你离开了那个人。我十几岁的时候在Best Buy面试或填过申请表，或者其他什么。好吧，我当时18或19岁，他们让你做这个性格测试之类的。真的吗？在电脑上？是的，是的。他们问你“你的同事偷了东西，你会怎么做？”比如
Yeah, yeah. It's like these things. And they think they're being like, ha-ha, like I made it a positive. But if you really do admit some deep flaw, I don't know. You leave the person. I interviewed or filled out an application for Best Buy one time when I was a teenager or whatever okay i was like 18 or 19 and um they make you take this like personality test or whatever do they really on the computer yeah yeah and they ask you like your co-worker has stolen something like what will you do like
你会告发他吗？你会……不，他们没那么说，但就像在严重程度上，这有多糟糕？比如你发现你的同事从办公室拿笔，然后在家里用，你的道德反应是什么？这有点令人不安，因为你的第一反应是想说“哦，偷窃是不对的，我向警察举报他”，但后来想，他们知道这一点。他们一定在寻找不同的东西。我把那个人关进监狱，因为他做了一些轻微的
will you rat him out will you no they didn't say that but like on like a severity like how bad is this like they your co-worker you found out your co-worker you know takes pens from the office uh and uses them at home like what's your moral reaction to that or whatever and it's like kind of disturbing because your immediate thing is like you want to say like oh stealing is bad like i report him to the police but then it's like well i don't they know that. They must be looking for something different. I throw the guy in jail because he did something minorly
错误。如果我那样说，他们可能不想雇我。有一个Ultima游戏，不是选择你的角色，比如骑士、吟游诗人、野蛮人等等，而是回答完全像这样的问题，然后根据你的回答显示你的职业。比如如果你
wrong. They probably don't want to hire me if I say that. There was one of the Ultima games where instead of choosing your character like knight or bard or barbarian or what have you, you answered questions exactly like this and then it shows your class depending on how you answered like if you if you
回答得非常死板，那么你最终会成为一名骑士。你知道，也许Best Buy也发生了同样的事情，如果你回答得让顾客即使在偷笔时也是对的，他们就会成为经理之类的，我不知道。等等，什么？我没得到那份工作，所以无论是什么，我不认为我回答正确了。哦，也许答案是去偷笔。等等，我不认为那……什么？什么？看，这就是相关性即因果关系。所以你写了你会抓住你的同事，你会举报他，但你没得到那份工作，因此正确的答案是让你的同事偷笔。我只是假设
answered everything like uh very letter of the law then you ended up a knight you know like maybe the same thing's happening at best buy like if you uh if you if you answered everything in a way that uh made the customer right even when they were stealing pens they became manager or something i don't know wait what i didn't get the job so whatever it is i don't think i answered correctly oh maybe the answers were to steal pens wait i don't think that what no what huh see that's correlation is causation so you put that you would catch your co-worker and like you'd report him and you didn't get the job therefore the correct answer is to let your co-worker get away with steel i just assumed
是因为我夸大了我的技术能力。好吧，他们害怕在Best Buy有这样的人。不，不，不，有一次，这有点题外话，但我去了CompUSA，我不知怎么地买了一张显卡，当时他们有服务助理，比如从后面拿显卡给你，和你交谈之类的。我想Fry's现在还在这样做，他们有佣金之类的。我不喜欢那样。哦，我讨厌那个。
it was because i overstated my technical competency okay they were scared about having someone at best buy no no no no one time it's kind of an aside but i went to comp usa and um you know i somehow it came up i was like buying a video card and at the time they had like a service assistant like you know like like you know get the video card from the back and give it to you and talk to you or whatever. I think Fry still does this and they get a commission or whatever. Which I don't like. Oh, I hate that.
我绝对讨厌它。关于驱动程序的事情出现了。这个有好的驱动程序之类的。我说，我用Linux，没关系。他说，除了听起来很酷，为什么有人会用Linux？我说，等等，那是个好问题。什么？
I absolutely hate it. Something came up about drivers. This one has good drivers or something. I said, I use Linux, it doesn't matter. He goes, other than it sounding cool, why would anybody use Linux? I was like, wait, that's a good question. What?
滚开。因为我不想下载我们花了一整集谈论的Unix工具。我希望它们就在那里。但实际上，你知道，我告诉他的是，我说，你知道，当你在学校时，他们教你，你知道，有那种敷衍了事的方法，然后有还可以的方法，还有很棒的方法。就像Windows用的是敷衍了事的方法，Linux用的是很棒的方法。当你学习，比如，是的，这是真的，当你学习交换文件管理或管理动态库时，你在大学里上操作系统101课程。总有三种不同的方法
Get out of here. Because I don't want to download my Unix tools that we spent a whole show talking about. I want them to just be there. But actually, you know, what I told him was, I was like, you know, when you're in school and they teach you you know there's like the half-ass way of doing things and then there's like the okay way and the great way it's like windows does the half-ass way and linux does a great way like when you learn about like like yeah it's true when you're over like swap file management or managing dynamic libraries you take your operating system 101 course in college. There's always three different ways
来解决问题。有糟糕的方法。有人们在思考正确方法时实现的方法。它还可以，但没那么好。然后有正确的方法，比其他两种都要好得多。而Linux总是做
to solve the problem. There's the terrible way. There's the way that people implemented while they were thinking of the right way. And it's okay, but it's not that great. And then there's the right way that's just way better than either of the other two. And Linux always does
第三种，Windows总是做第一种。那个论点也没用，CompUSA的那个人只是笑了笑之类的。总之，我再也没去过。你应该直接避免谈话。是的，吸取教训。如果你和Best Buy或CompUSA的任何人交谈，你会被拒绝工作，无论哪种方式，你都会不高兴地离开。我觉得我可能冒犯了人。如果你在Best Buy工作，我们很抱歉。是的，如果你在Best Buy工作，你可能很棒，我只是嫉妒，因为我没得到那份工作。是的，对吧。所以，我的话题其实有点难解释，极其难解释，但我试着把它可视化了。是的，完全正确，它字面上是一组数学可视化。
the third one, and Windows always does the first one. And that argument didn't work either the guy at CompUSA just laughed or whatever anyways I never went back you should have just avoided conversation yeah lesson learned if you if you talk to anybody at Best Buy or CompUSA you'll get rejected for a job and either way you'll leave unhappy i feel like i've probably offended people if you work at best buy we're sorry yeah if you work at best buy you're probably great i'm just jealous because i couldn't get the job yeah right so um my topic is a little hard to explain actually extremely hard to explain but i have tried visualizing it yeah exactly it is literally a group a collection of math visualizations
所以我通过Math Stack Exchange和Google Plus，一直在关注互联网上很多极客数学爱好者，书呆子。而且，是的，在这些周里，我遇到了一些惊人的可视化，我想和你们分享一下。显然，它们很难谈论，但我会简要尝试。你能给我们描述一段现代舞吗？是的，完全正确，我正在做。哦，我感到很高兴。是的。所以他们有像二项式定理，比如(A+B)的平方。他们把平方分配到A和B中，你知道，
so i'm uh through the math stack exchange and through google plus and i've been uh following a lot of like geeky math people on the internet nerd and uh yeah and throughout the uh um throughout the weeks i've been doing this i've come across some amazing visualizations and i wanted to kind of share those with you um obviously they're very hard to talk about but i'll try briefly can you describe to us an interpretive dance yeah exactly i'm doing it right now. Oh, I feel happy. Yeah. So they have like the binomial theorem where it's like A plus B parentheses squared. And they like distribute the squared, you know, through A and B.
所以它变成了A平方加2AB加B平方。这些总是你在初中或高中学到的那种东西。但它们实际上采用了形状。而且这些形状的面积，比如初中或高中，但它们实际上采用了形状，这些形状的面积是A平方或B平方，并向你展示这些形状是如何组合在一起的，以及为什么这有意义。他们对勾股定理和其他几件事也这样做。我觉得这很酷，我实际上加入了Math Google Plus社区，他们有一个专门针对这些他们发布的酷可视化的部分。
So it becomes like A squared plus 2AB plus B squared. They're always these kind of things that you learn in like middle school or high school. But they actually take shapes. And the shapes have an area of like middle school or high school but they actually take shapes and the shapes have an area of like a squared or b squared and actually show you how the shapes kind of come together and why that makes sense um they do this for the pythagorean theorem and a couple other things and uh i thought it was pretty cool i actually joined the math uh google plus community and they have a section just for these cool visualizations that they post
每隔几天左右，看看一些人对事物的看法有非常创造性的方式，这很酷。是的，我觉得有时人们除了在小学做的数学之外，更高级的数学，我们知道它的唯一方式是通过期刊论文中出现的图片之类的。出现在大众新闻中的东西会有图片，比如处理高维数的新方法，并展示一些酷的图片之类的。人们会说，哦，酷。
every like few days or so and it's just kind of cool to to look at some people have some really uh creative ways of looking at things it's very cool yeah i think sometimes like people other than like the math they do in grade school or whatever, the more advanced math, the only way we know it is through the pictures that end up in the journal papers or whatever. The stuff that ends up in popular news will have a picture, like new way of dealing with high dimensionality and show some cool picture or whatever. And people will be like, oh, cool.
所以你拥有的图片越多，我想，人们就越觉得你的数学很酷。是的，正如我们在节目开始前谈到的，我觉得人们实际上是通过这些图片学习这些定理的，你知道？我的意思是，发现勾股定理的希腊罗马人，你知道，毕达哥拉斯并没有发现勾股定理。那是一个常见的误解，它只是以他的名字命名，因为他经营那所学校之类的。但无论如何，他们可能
So the more pictures you have, I guess, the more cool people think your math is. Yeah, and as we were talking about before the show, like, I feel like the people actually learned these theorems through these pictures, you know? I mean, the Greco-Romans who discovered, you know, Pythagorean theorem, which, you know, Pythagoras did not discover Pythagorean theorem. That's, like like a common misconception he's just named after him because he ran the school or whatever but at any rate they probably
做过这个，他们在木板上放了一堆三角形和正方形之类的，并想象了几乎所有这些定理。所以我认为通过这些图片重新发明它很酷。如果你做不到，你至少可以使用Wolfram语言。Wolfram语言是……我本来想说，在我看一部关于数学历史的纪录片之前，
did this, they had a bunch of triangles and squares on sheets of wood or something and visualized almost all of these theorems I'm imagining so it's kind of cool to read to like to reinvent that yourself through these pictures and if you can't do that you can at least use wolfram language wolfram language is oh i was gonna say before i watched a part of a documentary about the history of math
然后我感到无聊，我就停止看了，但他们说苏美尔人在公元前第三个千年使用了60进制的数字系统。什么？哦，因为我猜，我猜那是因为，那实际上就是时间，对吧？所以这就是他们所说的，这些人实际上是天才之类的。他们用手指关节计数，而不是手指。总之，是的。所以是60进制。这太疯狂了。
and then i got bored and i stopped watching it but they were saying that the sumerians in third millennium bc used a base 60 numbering system what oh because i guess i guess that's because like that's what time is effectively right so that's what they're saying like these people were actually like genius or whatever. And they were like count using like kind of the knuckles in their hands as opposed to fingers. And anyways, yeah. So base 60. And it's crazy.
而且我们今天仍然保留着它的遗迹。哦，那真的很有趣。总之，也许我会在这里添加链接，我们可以把它放在节目笔记里。但有一部BBC关于数学的纪录片，如果你能看完的话。好吧，那么Wolfram语言。我看到它实际上是上周才出来的，我相信。Wolfram，我忘了那个人的名字。
And we still have like vestiges of it left over until today. Oh, that's really interesting. Anyway, so maybe I'll add the link here, and we can put it in the show notes. But there's this documentary from the BBC on math, if you can make it through it. Okay, so Wolfram language. I saw it came out actually just last week, I believe. Wolfram, I forget the guy's first name.
我想他的姓是Wolfram。Stephen Wolfram。那个有Wolfram Alpha的人。我们称它为搜索引擎吗？我不记得他们叫它什么了，我想它被称为数学搜索引擎之类的，或者计算引擎。所以他有那个，据说是基于他一直在研究的东西，他有一本书，我想甚至可能是在线的，描述了他那种处理数学的理论，以及他做的这类事情。他做的不仅仅是制作一个用于数学处理的软件包，他试图做更多。而且他有一种他一直在研究的编程语言，其中一部分是函数式描述，
I think his last name is Wolfram. Stephen Wolfram. The guy who has Wolfram Alpha. Do we call it a search engine? i don't remember what they call it they have i think it's called like a math search engine or something or computation engine so he has like that is supposed to be based on this thing he's been working on and he has a book uh i think it might even be online that like describes like his kind of theory of like working with math and this kind of stuff he does a lot more than just like make a software package for doing math processing like he's trying to do more and um he has a programming language he's been working on and part of it is a functional description
然后他试图把它和其他很多东西整合在一起，所以你可以说它理解关于位置的事情，所以如果你说“美国各州的首都”或某种规范，你可以得到“这是所有的首府城市”，然后你可以做一些事情，比如“城市人口”，语言本身知道如何去获取这些信息并原生显示给你。然后，你知道，展示一些关于拥有某种图形并将其参数化，并且只用几行代码就能完成的事情。所以有一个YouTube视频，我们会把它放在节目笔记里，你可能已经看过了，Wolfram语言，它有所有这些不同的部分，这个非常流畅的视频，他展示了它。它看起来确实很有趣，看起来非常不同。我不知道我
and then he's trying to integrate it like with a lot of other stuff so you can say like it understands things about location so if you say capitals of states um your capitals of states in the united states or some specification you can get like here are all the capital cities and then you can do things like population of cities and the language itself knows how to like go fetch that information and natively display it to you um and then like you know shows things about kind of having some graphic and then having it parameterized and like doing it in only like a couple lines of code so there's a youtube video we'll put it in the show notes you may have already seen it um the wolfram language and it has like all these different pieces and this real slick video he shows um and it does seem kind of interesting it seems very different like i don't know how i
对它感觉如何，因为有语言本身，但还有所有这些其他东西，我们谈到Python是“电池内置”，但这里甚至比仅仅是“这里有其他代码库”更进一步，而是数据。我想这就是重点，它谈论的是让数据成为语言的一部分，你可以原生了解一些数据，这对于一种语言来说是不正常的，至少不是我思考它的方式。是的，当有人给你一种语言、编译器或解释器时，这真是太神奇了，它有这么多东西，甚至无法真正装进你的电脑。
feel about it because like there is like the language itself but then there's all this other stuff as well which we talked about like python being batteries included but here even going further than just like here's other libraries of code but like data i guess that's the thing it's like this talks about having kind of data be a part of the language where you can natively know bits of data um and that's not normal for a language at least like not the way i think about it yeah that's pretty amazing when somebody gives you a language a compiler as it were an interpreter that like it has so much you know stuff that won't even really fit on your computer.
就像我认为它必须连接到网络才能获取其中一些信息。否则它会变得非常庞大。我会假设。是的，我的意思是，能够统一这些可能是非常定性的数据，对吧。这真是太神奇了。是的。但这也是其中之一。比如我挠挠头想，哦，那很灵巧，
Like I think it has to be connected to the web to be able to get some of this information. Cause otherwise it would just be massive. I would assume. Yeah. I mean, being able to sort of like unify this data that might be like very qualitative, right. It's kind of amazing. Yeah. But it's one of those things too. Like I scratched my head and think like, oh, that's nifty,
但就像如果你曾经尝试在Android或iOS上进行语音搜索，并且你尝试以某种对你来说最自然的方式说出特定的命令，它并不总是有效。嗯，因为它在期待一个不同的关键词。一旦你知道了关键词，它在理解你在说什么方面做得相当好。比如，“带我回家”最初可能不起作用。我想现在它起作用了。你必须说“导航回家”。它知道家是什么，
but it's like if you ever try to do voice search on Android or iOS and you try to like say a specific command in a certain way, that's the most natural to you. It doesn't always work. Um, because like it's expecting a different keyword. And as soon as you know, the keyword, it does a pretty good job of understanding what you're saying. Like, take me home might not work initially. I think it does work now. You have to say navigate home. Like it knows what home is,
但不是从概念上。它只是把它作为一个关键词。所以你必须说“导航回家”，但说“带我回家”或“我怎么回家？”它，除非它被编程为知道它无法弄清楚。是的。
but not conceptually. It just knows it as like a keyword. And so you have to say navigate home, but saying like, take me home or how do I get home? It, unless it's programmed to know that it can't figure it out. Yeah.
我的意思是，你认为有时我怀疑你是否能纯粹通过人们互动的统计数据来解决这个问题？换句话说，足够多的人说“带我回家”，然后失败了，然后他们说“获取回家的路线”，随着时间的推移，你可以了解到“带我”做那个。是的，有些东西据说确实做到了。但我怀疑这是否足够。我的意思是，当我还是本科生时，有一门关于自然语言处理的完整课程，所有这些疯狂的框架，所有这些人类，你知道，词性标注，所有这些疯狂的东西，人们做了所有这些他们使用的启发式方法，有时我
I mean, do you think that like sometimes i wonder if you can solve this purely through just like statistics of of people's interactions in other words like enough people say take me home and then that fails and then they say get directions to home that like you over time can learn that taking stuff does that yeah some stuff is supposedly does that like i wonder if that's enough though like i you know i mean when i was an undergrad there was this whole course on like natural language processing and all of this crazy amount of like frames and all this like human you know like like part of speech tagging all of this crazy stuff that people did all these heuristics they use and sometimes i
怀疑你是否真的需要任何这些，或者如果你有足够的数据，你是否可以通过推理完成几乎所有事情。对吧？是的，我不知道，这很难。但，我提到这些其他东西的原因，关于语音搜索，是想说像Wolfram语言，所有这些惊人的东西，但有很多东西要记住。你不可能记住它，所以即使你用Java编写，也会发生同样的事情，对吧？你可能，除非你真的很擅长，否则不会记住Java所有部分的每一个方面，但做很多事情的部分，你可以知道，你可以知道语言的大部分和细微差别。但对于这样的东西，它可能会经常改变，我会假设，因为数据部分，就像你
wonder if you really need any of that or if you can do almost everything through just inference if you had enough data right yeah i don't know it's tough but um the reason i was bringing up this other stuff or whatever about um you know the voice searches to say like ns wolfram language like all these amazing things but like there's a lot of stuff to memorize there's no way you can memorize it so like the same thing happens even if you write in like java right you probably unless you're like really good like memorize every aspect of all the parts of java but the parts to do like like a lot of stuff you can know like you can know the majority of the language and the nuances but with something like this it would probably change often i would assume like because of the data part like you
会有，现在我们有，我不知道，动物物种。哦，好吧，现在这里有关键词。就像你必须不断地处于那种查找东西的模式，以知道使用什么关键词来获取该数据。是的，然后该数据可能可用也可能不可用，对吧？而不是像坐下来，说“好吧，我有这一小套碎片，并弄清楚如何安排它们来做我想做的事”。是的，我的意思是，你几乎会产生广场恐惧症，有太多的事情在发生，以至于你甚至无法真正开始。是的，但去看看那个视频，它很酷。它有一些合作关系，我想，我正在努力回忆，我没在节目开始前看它，但，嗯，有一些他们正在用Raspberry
would have now we have um i don't know species of animals oh okay well now like here's the keywords for that it's like you would constantly have to be in the mode of like looking stuff up to know what what keyword to use to get at that data um yeah and then that data may or may not be available right versus just like sitting down and saying okay i have this small set of pieces and figuring out how to arrange them to do what i want yeah i mean you get like almost like agoraphobia there's just like so much stuff going on that you can't even really get started yeah but but check out the video it's cool uh it's yeah it has some partnership i think i uh with i'm trying to remember now i didn't look at it right before the show but uh um i there's something where they're doing with the raspberry
Pi做的事情，Raspberry Pi附带了一个Wolfram版本的什么东西。哦，有趣。我想他们也会尝试这样做，与他们进行某种合作。我最近使用了WolframAlpha，我需要计算，比如，我需要从正态分布的累积分布函数中采样。所以你最终会有一个函数叫IRF，比如E-R-F。我想它代表误差率函数。这个函数是根据它本身定义的，就像erf(x)等于blah blah blah乘以e的erf(x)除以2，所以我只是，什么？什么？
pies like raspberry pie ships with a version of wolfram something oh interesting and i think they're going to try to do this as well, some partnership with them. I used WolframAlpha recently to, I needed to calculate, like, the, I needed to sample from the cumulative distribution function of, like, normal distribution. So you end up having a, there's this function called IRF, like E-R-F. I think it stands for, like, error rate function. And the function is defined in terms of itself it's like erf of x is equal to blah blah blah times e to the erf of x over two and so i'm just like what what
像树莓派这样的设备预装了Wolfram的某个版本，哦，真有意思，我想他们也打算这样做，和他们建立某种合作关系。我最近用了WolframAlpha，因为我需要计算，比如，我需要从正态分布的累积分布函数中进行采样。所以你最终会得到一个函数，叫IRF，也就是E-R-F。我想它代表的是误差函数。这个函数的定义是基于它自身的，就像erf(x)等于blah blah blah乘以e的erf(x)除以2，所以我当时就想，这到底是什么？
so and i had to like integrate that i was like what so i went on wolfram alpha and uh it's amazing actually they show you how to do it it's really impressive like there's a there's a technique you can use which of course you can't you can't get the exact answer you know just you could tell right away that like a recurrence like this like it's never gonna end you know it's like one of these like infinite series right but uh but it shows you like what people do like in industry and stuff to to get answers and uh i was really impressed by wolf all right it's time for book of the show book of the show so uh my book's actually a comic book um i thought it was pretty cool it's called my friend dommer and it's written by um somebody who went to high school with uh jeffrey dahmer who is a notorious murder slash
所以我不得不整合它，我当时想“什么？”，所以我去了 Wolfram Alpha，实际上它真的很神奇，它会向你展示如何去做，这真的很令人印象深刻，比如有一种你可以使用的技巧，当然你无法得到确切的答案，你知道，你一眼就能看出像这样的递归永远不会结束，你知道，它就像这些无穷级数之一，对吧？但它向你展示了人们在工业界等领域是如何获得答案的，我对 Wolfram 印象非常深刻。好了，现在是节目推荐书的时间，节目推荐书，所以我的书其实是一本漫画书，我觉得它很酷，它叫《我的朋友达默》，是由一位和杰弗里·达默上过高中的人写的，杰弗里·达默是一个臭名昭著的谋杀犯兼
cannibal um wait what yeah i mean basically you know shortly after high school you know throughout high school he was pretty crazy and you know he just kind of got worse and worse and then within a few years of high school graduating high school he he killed this lady who was jogging near his house but wait this is in real life well this is a real story what I'm talking about now really happened and literally he cannibalized
食人者，等等，什么？是的，我的意思是，基本上，你知道，高中毕业后不久，你知道，在整个高中期间，他都很疯狂，你知道，他只是变得越来越糟，然后在高中毕业后的几年内，他杀害了在他家附近慢跑的这位女士，等等，这是在现实生活中吗？嗯，这是一个真实的故事，我现在说的确实发生了，而且他真的吃掉了
this poor lady and then he proceeded to murder and cannibalize people until he was caught and he ended up getting an electric chair but the comic book is illustrated it's written from the perspective of this guy who went to high school with him and it's really interesting, it's all about this was I guess in the 70s
这位可怜的女士，然后他继续谋杀和吃人，直到他被抓住，最后他被判处电刑，但这本书有插图，它是从这位和他一起上高中的人的角度写的，这真的很有趣，这一切都是关于，我想这是在 70 年代
and I think people are much more in touch with mental disabilities interesting it's all about basically you know this was i guess in the 70s and you know i think people are much more in touch with like mental disabilities and and and you know these things are taken much more seriously especially after columbine and so on and so forth just in general people are much more like empathic towards these kind of mental problems than they were back then um and it just it just you know he just goes through just like the person was like he was pretty bad when he was like 14 he was already kind of messed up and then throughout high school how like things really just go from bad to worse and everyone's just kind of making fun of it you know like his classmates and stuff was kind of
而且我认为人们对精神障碍的了解要多得多，有趣的是，这一切基本上都是关于，你知道，我想这是在 70 年代，而且你知道，我认为人们对精神障碍的了解要多得多，而且你知道，这些事情被看得更严重了，特别是在科伦拜恩事件之后等等，总的来说，人们对这些精神问题比当时更有同理心，嗯，他只是，你知道，他只是经历了一切，就像那个人一样，他 14 岁时就很糟糕，他已经有点混乱了，然后在整个高中期间，事情真的从坏变得更糟，每个人都在取笑它，你知道，就像他的同学之类的，有点
making fun of the situation but really it's just very serious that he's kind of messed up you know and uh um you know and and the show ends with them all graduating high school and then there's a short narrative about you know what happens after that but i just i the whole thing was it was of course very somber but it was also really interesting. And the guy starts the comic book by saying, you know, I'm self-publishing this book because nobody would publish it for me. Nobody wanted to get near this subject because they thought it was like too touchy and they didn't want to deal with the problems, the fallout or whatever. So I paid for the publishing myself. And it's just that kind of gets your attention. And then from then on, the whole thing or whatever. So I paid for the publishing myself. And it's just, that kind of gets your attention, right?
在取笑这种情况，但实际上这非常严重，他有点混乱，你知道，嗯，你知道，节目以他们高中毕业结束，然后有一个简短的叙述，关于你知道之后发生了什么，但我只是，整个事情当然非常沉重，但也真的很有趣。那个人在漫画书的开头说，你知道，我正在自费出版这本书，因为没有人愿意为我出版。没有人想接近这个主题，因为他们认为这太敏感了，他们不想处理这些问题、后果什么的。所以我自己支付了出版费用。这确实引起了你的注意。然后从那时起，整个事情，或者其他什么。所以我自己支付了出版费用。这确实引起了你的注意，对吧？
And then from then on, the whole thing is actually pretty interesting. And it's not too, like, you know, the whole thing takes place before he started, you know, murdering people. So it's not graphic or bloody or anything like that. But it's, like, it's actually, like, it's a very somber
然后从那时起，整个事情其实很有趣。而且它不是太，你知道，整个事情发生在他开始，你知道，谋杀人之前。所以它不像那样有画面感或血腥。但它，就像，它实际上，就像，它是一个非常沉重的
story. And it's actually really interesting. So I recommend reading it. Yeah, I don it's a very somber story. It's actually really interesting. So I recommend reading it. Yeah, I don't know how to follow that up. Yeah, it's pretty deep. Don't read it when you want, like, you know, feel good. But I got a lot out of it. I thought it was interesting. Okay.
故事。而且它实际上真的很有趣。所以我建议阅读它。是的，我不知道该怎么接下去。是的，它很深刻。当你想要，你知道，感觉良好时不要读它。但我从中学到了很多。我觉得它很有趣。好的。
My book of the show is a magazine. All right. Make magazine. You're the the show is a magazine. All right. Well, that's good. Make Magazine. You're the ying to my yang. It has nothing to do with cannibals as far as I know. So if you've not seen this before, I don't know if they sell it overseas, but at least in America they have this magazine, Make Magazine.
我的节目推荐书是一本杂志。好的。《Make》杂志。你是节目是杂志。好的。嗯，那很好。《Make》杂志。你是我的阴阳。据我所知，它与食人者无关。所以如果你以前没见过这个，我不知道他们是否在海外销售，但至少在美国他们有这本杂志，《Make》杂志。
It's been going on for probably like four or five years now. I don't actually know. I'd have to look it up. Oh, really? I felt like it's been around forever. You think longer than that? Maybe. Maybe I'm thinking of something else.
它可能已经发行了四五年了。我其实不知道。我得查一下。哦，真的吗？我觉得它好像一直都在。你认为比那更久吗？也许吧。也许我在想别的事情。
We have to look it up. So I think they come out with four a year. So quarterly, I believe, is how often it comes out. I'm not. I'd have to look it up again. But they have a lot of really awesome DIY projects and and articles and talking to people doing that kind of thing. So like recently I was reading, I think issue 36 or whatever. I think they're on issue 37 right now.
我们得查一下。所以我认为他们一年出四期。所以我相信它是季刊。我不是。我得再查一下。但他们有很多非常棒的 DIY 项目和文章，并与做这类事情的人交谈。所以最近我在读，我想是第 36 期什么的。我想他们现在在第 37 期。
And they were talking about the Internet of Things. They were talking to some people who are doing a startup about Internet of Things and kind of what that means and what it's about and how they did it. And then they have like typically a couple tutorials on how to build something so the one i was reading about was doing fusion in a jar and oh nice i really want to try it like it seems really awesome um and you get this kind of glowing star basically in in a jar um and you but it requires like all sorts of crazy equipment right not crazy but like i don't have it equipment so things like vacuum pumps and neon sign transformers and um you know some special materials and uh but when you do it it's just like wow this is the kind of thing like i wish i could have done this for like science fair stuff. It would have been like, you know, amazing or whatever.
他们在谈论物联网。他们正在与一些正在做物联网创业的人交谈，以及这意味着什么，它是关于什么的，以及他们是如何做到的。然后他们通常会有几个关于如何构建东西的教程，所以我正在读的那个是关于在罐子里做聚变，哦，不错，我真的很想尝试一下，它看起来真的很棒，嗯，你基本上在罐子里得到了这种发光的星星，嗯，但它需要各种疯狂的设备，对吧，不是疯狂，而是像我没有的设备，所以像真空泵和霓虹灯变压器，嗯，你知道一些特殊的材料，嗯，但当你做的时候，它就像“哇，这就是我希望我能为科学展览做的那种事情”。那会是，你知道，令人惊叹的什么的。
And then they have, you know, less, less crazy stuff, but even just to like sit there and read through it and think about it and kind of, you know, just be in that culture of like how to make something that you may have thought required like a factory to make it and, you know, making it yourself that kind of of spirit is i like i like a lot i like reading the magazine yeah i mean i think that inspired it's really interesting that like uh you know i felt like when i was really interested in in these kind of things you know
然后他们有，你知道，不那么疯狂的东西，但即使只是坐在那里读它并思考它，并以某种方式，你知道，只是处于那种文化中，比如如何制作你可能认为需要工厂才能制造的东西，而且，你知道，自己制作它，那种精神我喜欢，我喜欢读这本杂志，是的，我的意思是，我认为这激发了灵感，这真的很有趣，就像，嗯，你知道，我觉得当我真的对这些事情感兴趣时，你知道
when we were both uh working together like on the east coast um you know at the time 3d printers were not popular at all and i built like a lot of electronic kind of things but i never got to actually enclose any of the electronics and make something which i would work day to day you know and uh i just think it's absolutely amazing how you know what five six years later we could actually you know fabricate something that would be like almost professional quality you know just for you know a few thousand dollars of equipment right yeah it's pretty amazing and it ties in with our theme which we'll talk about in a minute our show topic but yeah i mean stuff is changing so eight years ago it started just just shy of eight years ago january 2005 so i was off um but yeah i mean stuff is changing so eight years ago it started just just shy of eight years ago
当我们都在东海岸一起工作时，嗯，你知道，当时 3D 打印机根本不流行，我建造了很多电子产品，但我从来没有真正把任何电子产品封装起来并制作出我每天都能使用的东西，你知道，嗯，我只是觉得这绝对令人惊叹，你知道，五年六年后，我们实际上可以，你知道，制造出几乎是专业质量的东西，你知道，只需几千美元的设备，对吧？是的，这太令人惊叹了，它与我们的主题联系在一起，我们稍后会谈论我们的节目主题，但是的，我的意思是事情正在改变，所以八年前它开始了，就在八年前，2005 年 1 月，所以我错了，但是的，我的意思是事情正在改变，所以八年前它开始了，就在八年前
january 2005 so it's i was off um but yeah if you've never checked it out before um they have a blog and they post like you know projects people do and uh is the magazine free or how does it work no no no so the magazine is paid uh and it's a little expensive and it comes out quarterly but i mean it's how much is it roughly i think uh i want to say like six seven dollars maybe eight dollars seven dollars so like uh thirty dollars a year yeah i think it's maybe thirty five dollars a year okay that's not bad i mean for four four yeah so i mean you're not doing it because it's like cheap uh but it is uh you know it's a good read and i don't know where else you get it for like what kind of material.
2005 年 1 月，所以我错了，嗯，但是的，如果你以前从未看过它，嗯，他们有一个博客，他们发布人们做的项目，嗯，杂志是免费的还是怎么运作的？不，不，所以杂志是付费的，而且有点贵，它是季刊，但我的意思是，它大约多少钱？我想，嗯，我想说大约六七美元，也许八美元，七美元，所以大约一年三十美元，是的，我想也许一年三十五美元，好的，那还不错，我的意思是四期，是的，所以我的意思是，你不是因为便宜才买它，嗯，但它是，你知道，这是一本好读物，我不知道你在哪里还能得到像这种材料的东西。
Okay. So it looks like it's maybe $10 an issue or at least the most recent issue is $10 on Amazon, but it's probably like what a hundred pages or so. Yeah. It's nice. It's thick. It's I don't know how many pages it is.
好的。所以看起来每期可能 10 美元，或者至少亚马逊上最近的一期是 10 美元，但它可能有一百页左右。是的。它很好。它很厚。我不知道它有多少页。
I have no way of estimating. It's not, I don't think it's that unreasonable really. I mean, I think magazines are magazine is like uh it's one of these words that sort of like gives gives away the price and the word you know like if you say magazine there's an expectation that it should be like three dollars you know yeah but really like something like this which it sounds like it's it's it's a whole volume right yeah i mean it's a lot of material and that
我无法估计。我不认为它真的那么不合理。我的意思是，我认为杂志是杂志，就像，嗯，它是这些词之一，有点像，泄露了价格和词，你知道，就像如果你说杂志，有一种期望它应该是三美元，你知道，是的，但实际上像这样的东西，听起来它是一个完整的卷，对吧？是的，我的意思是它有很多材料，而且那个
stuff is longer form and yeah it's hard right because sometimes i go to like what am i gonna read and it's like you can read comic books right but like they're they're also somewhat expensive for how long it takes to read like a single comic book which is something i never quite understood like for me like oh by at least the what are the ones that come like batman every every week or every month oh yeah like the superhero and it's like what i don't know what it's what prices are now like four dollars for an issue or something and it's like but i could read that issue very quickly um no that's just to get the story now i can go back and look at the pictures and think about it right longer or whatever but like just reading the story through is very quick but for ten dollars i can buy
东西是长篇的，是的，这很难，因为有时我去，比如我要读什么，就像你可以读漫画书，对吧？但它们对于读一本漫画书需要多长时间来说也相当贵，这是我从来没有完全理解的事情，就像对我来说，哦，至少买那些，比如蝙蝠侠，每周或每月出的那些，哦，是的，就像超级英雄，就像什么，我不知道现在的价格是多少，比如四美元一期什么的，就像，但我可以很快读完那一期，嗯，不，那只是为了得到故事，现在我可以回去看图片并思考它，对吧，更久什么的，但就像读完故事本身非常快，但花十美元我可以买
a 800 page science fiction novel um you know that will take me like months to read yeah yeah exactly yeah i never you know even like now with the digital era the prices are more reasonable but still you know this the whole superhero comic thing i just i agree i think the pricing model is just ridiculous and and part of it too is like i think the people who who get those comics they're they get it mainly for the art you know because the story i'm probably going to offend every comic book follower but i mean the story on superhero comics i just never could really get that into it it never was that compelling you know yeah i i don't know i always wanted to be into comic books but like my my parents never really
一本 800 页的科幻小说，你知道，那需要我几个月的时间来读，是的，是的，完全正确，是的，我从来没有，你知道，即使现在有了数字时代，价格更合理了，但仍然，你知道，这个整个超级英雄漫画的事情，我只是，我同意，我认为定价模型简直荒谬，而且部分原因也是，就像我认为那些买那些漫画的人，他们主要是为了艺术而买的，你知道，因为故事，我可能会冒犯每一个漫画书追随者，但我的意思是超级英雄漫画的故事，我从来没有真正进入过它，它从来没有那么引人注目，你知道，是的，我不知道，我一直想进入漫画书，但就像我的父母从来没有真正
like offered to buy them for me or take me to where they were bought and there wasn't any place close to me um i gotcha and so like i never really got into it and then like as an adult there's still like somewhat of a stigma attached to it. Like, it's a childish thing or whatever. And with the movies, like, I wear T-shirts that have superhero stuff on them and nobody seems to mind. But, like, reading comics is kind of, like, seen as childish. I'm not exactly sure where that came from. Isn't that interesting?
像主动给我买它们或带我去买它们的地方，而且我附近没有任何地方，嗯，我明白了，所以就像我从来没有真正进入过它，然后作为成年人，仍然有一种与之相关的耻辱感。就像，这是一件幼稚的事情什么的。而且有了电影，就像，我穿有超级英雄东西的 T 恤，没人介意。但是，就像，读漫画被认为有点幼稚。我不确定这是从哪里来的。这不有趣吗？
Like, if you were to wear, like, an Iron Manshirt which i do 10 years ago people would be like that guy is you know he must have been they wouldn't know what it is like but yeah well that's true too but uh but yeah now it's like because it's in the movies it's okay yeah all right okay time for tool of the show tool of the show so my tool of the show is you select I download, which is pretty cool. It's a it's a plugin for Chrome. I don't know if anyone else has had this problem, or if it's just me. But if you have you ever go to those web pages, you know, most of the time, it might be like internal, like, like, like the Hadoop, you you know front end or whatever or some kind of page but it just it has a ton of links like i'll give you another example the um the google books data set which
就像，如果你穿，比如，一件钢铁侠衬衫，我 10 年前穿过，人们会说那个人是，你知道，他一定是，他们不知道那是什么，就像，但是的，好吧，那也是真的，但嗯，但是的，现在就像因为它是电影里的，所以没关系，是的，好的，好的，节目工具时间，节目工具时间，所以我的节目工具是你选择我下载，这很酷。它是 Chrome 的一个插件。我不知道还有没有人遇到过这个问题，或者只是我。但如果你曾经去过那些网页，你知道，大多数时候，它可能是内部的，比如，比如，比如 Hadoop，你知道前端什么的，或者某种页面，但它只是有很多链接，比如我会给你另一个例子，嗯，谷歌图书数据集，它
which is available for download um is literally like a hundred links like you have to click on one by one and so um i found this pretty awesome link that basically is sort of like you kind of click and drag a lasso as if you're going to take a screenshot or something like that but then after this lasso it colors anything inside that lasso yellow and any links yellow and then if you hit shift enter it'll open all of those links in a new window so in other words like if you had this plugin you could click the plugin on top right select all the links for hacker news front page shift enter and they'll all open in in a different tab um and if you hit alt enter it automatically downloads them all. And it has some built-in download manager.
可以下载，嗯，字面上有一百个链接，你必须一个一个点击，所以嗯，我发现了这个非常棒的链接，基本上就像你点击并拖动一个套索，就像你要截屏什么的，但在这个套索之后，它把套索内的任何东西涂成黄色，任何链接涂成黄色，然后如果你按 Shift Enter，它会在新窗口中打开所有这些链接，换句话说，就像如果你有这个插件，你可以点击右上角的插件，选择黑客新闻首页的所有链接，Shift Enter，它们都会在不同的标签页中打开，嗯，如果你按 Alt Enter，它会自动下载它们。它有一些内置的下载管理器。
So it like breaks it up into chunks. It does it like really efficiently and so on and so forth. So I thought this was pretty cool. And I had to use it rather recently, but it worked extremely well. And it's pretty lightweight. It's just a Chrome plugin. So give it a shot. I do find that annoying i always
所以它把它分成块。它做得非常有效率等等。所以我认为这很酷。我最近不得不使用它，但它工作得非常好。而且它很轻量。它只是一个 Chrome 插件。所以试一试。我确实觉得这很烦人，我总是
want to write to like people who have pages like this and like is there any other way you could provide this to me yeah yeah i don't uh it doesn't happen that much anymore um it's pretty rare to have this have this situation although i had it you know this week but uh for the most part you know people i guess why do why do you think that doesn't happen anymore maybe there's just people although I had it this week. But for the most part, people, I guess, why do you think that doesn't happen anymore? Maybe there's just people have bigger files. People got smarter. I don't know.
想写信给那些有这样页面的人，比如还有其他方式可以提供给我吗？是的，是的，我不，嗯，这种情况不再经常发生了，嗯，有这种情况非常罕见，尽管我本周遇到了，但嗯，在大多数情况下，你知道，人们，我猜，你认为为什么这种情况不再发生了？也许只是人们，尽管我本周遇到了。但在大多数情况下，人们，我猜，你认为为什么这种情况不再发生了？也许只是人们有更大的文件。人们变聪明了。我不知道。
I think that you just don't have to download files in pieces anymore. I mean, this particular data set was like 17 terabytes or something ridiculous. So it was still broken up into pieces. But yeah, for the most part the days of downloading part 99 of 100 you know as a separate file are over all right so i was just realizing i might have said this one last time i was looking back at the log for my tool
我认为你只是不再需要分块下载文件了。我的意思是，这个特定的数据集有 17 TB 左右，或者类似荒谬的东西。所以它仍然被分成几块。但是的，在大多数情况下，下载 100 个文件中的第 99 个作为单独文件的日子已经结束了，好的，所以我刚才意识到我上次可能说过这个，我正在回顾我的工具的日志
of the show but it looks like it got copied from the previous one so it said kai cad twice in a row so i have no idea what i said last time but i if it was this one it makes it that much better that i still think it's thought about it this time okay and that's a game skulls of the shogun and uh jason's about to tell me that this is my uh you're in the clear oh good yes this is a game it used to be on the xbox i think the xbox 360 i guess arcade um and now it's on ios i don't know if it's on android i didn't look um i'm terrible i don't do the android thing as much as i guess i should as a jason's gonna make fun of me that i'm basically the linux guy on non-linux guy oh well it's okay wait so on ios skulls of the shogun and the difference here is ios does everything the better way anyways okay all right good good i feel better
节目，但看起来它是从上一个复制过来的，所以它连续两次说了 Kai Cad，所以我不知道我上次说了什么，但如果它是这个，它让它变得更好，我这次仍然想到了它，好的，那是一个游戏《幕府将军的头骨》，嗯，杰森正要告诉我这是我的，嗯，你很清楚，哦，好，是的，这是一个游戏，它曾经在 Xbox 上，我想是 Xbox 360，我猜是街机，嗯，现在它在 iOS 上，我不知道它是否在 Android 上，我没看，嗯，我很糟糕，我没有像我应该做的那样多做 Android 的事情，作为一个杰森要取笑我，我基本上是 Linux 上的非 Linux 人，哦，好吧，没关系，等等，所以在 iOS 上，《幕府将军的头骨》，这里的区别是 iOS 无论如何都以更好的方式做所有事情，好的，好的，好，我感觉好多了
now i feel better now um so if i now shift slightly to say that what i'm using is black bear no okay um skulls of the show is a strategy game uh on ios and i was we had a conversation a couple episodes back where i was saying like i always want to be good at strategy games and i'm always terrible at them and for some reason i do well at this game it's a turn-based strategy game where you are like a shogun who has died and went to the afterlife but someone one of your enemies that you killed went there before you obviously and claimed to be you uh and like there was like a special place in the afterlife set up for you because you were such a good shogun um and instead he's claimed this place or whatever and so now you're like fighting through the afterlife to get to him so that you can become
现在我感觉好多了，嗯，所以如果我现在稍微转移一下，说我正在使用的是黑熊，不，好的，嗯，《幕府将军的头骨》是一个策略游戏，嗯，在 iOS 上，我们几集前进行了一次对话，我说就像我一直想擅长策略游戏，但我总是很糟糕，出于某种原因，我在这个游戏中做得很好，这是一个回合制策略游戏，你就像一个已经死亡并去了来世的幕府将军，但有人，你杀死的敌人之一，显然在你之前去了那里，并声称是你，嗯，就像来世有一个为你准备的特殊地方，因为你是一个如此好的幕府将军，嗯，相反，他声称了这个地方什么的，所以现在你就像在来世中战斗以到达他那里，这样你就可以成为
who like reclaim yourself or something wow that's a pretty uh involved story no it's really it's really like goofy um okay it's not that serious and the animation style is crazy and it's all this kind of like skeleton zombie-ish like people or whatever um but you have like kind of the shogun style like you have uh i don't know if that's a style but like you know you have samurai and you have guys on horseback and guys with bows and arrows and your shogun who's like very powerful but if if he dies you lose um and so like you want to use them but like you can't put them at risk um and they have some interesting mechanics like if you're next to a cliff when you hit someone they get like pushed back a little. And if they fall off the cliff, they die.
谁，比如夺回你自己什么的，哇，那是一个非常，嗯，复杂的故事情节，不，它真的，它真的，就像傻乎乎的，好的，它没那么严肃，动画风格很疯狂，它全是这种，就像骷髅僵尸一样的人什么的，嗯，但你有，就像幕府将军风格，就像你有，嗯，我不知道那是不是一种风格，但就像，你知道，你有武士，你有骑马的人，有拿弓箭的人，还有你的幕府将军，他非常强大，但如果他死了，你就输了，嗯，所以就像你想使用他们，但就像你不能让他们冒险，嗯，他们有一些有趣的机制，比如如果你在悬崖边上，当你击中某人时，他们会被推后一点。如果他们掉下悬崖，他们就死了。
So you can try to like, there are approaches where there's like narrow stuff and you have to be careful about who goes through so that your people don't get knocked off the cliff. But for some reason, this strategy game, I seem to be doing okay. It's probably because I have it on easy setting. Are you playing against a computer or against people? Yeah, so they have against people, but I haven't tried that yet because I don't want to be embarrassed. And I'm thinking highly of myself at present. Oh, my goodness. Have you been on their website?
所以你可以尝试，比如，有狭窄的东西的方法，你必须小心谁通过，这样你的人就不会被撞下悬崖。但出于某种原因，这个策略游戏，我似乎做得还可以。这可能是因为我把它设置在简单模式。你是和电脑玩还是和人玩？是的，所以他们有和人玩，但我还没试过，因为我不想尴尬。而且我现在对自己评价很高。哦，天哪。你去过他们的网站吗？
No. They have, if you click on, if you go to their website, Are you going to talk about the trailer? Because the reason I bought the game was because of the trailer. Oh, really? Well, I was going to say, if you click on team, they have pictures of the employees and they're hilarious. Okay. But yeah, so what about the trailer oh really well i was gonna say if you click on team uh they have pictures of the employees and they're hilarious okay but yeah so what about the trailer so if you watch the trailer it's like a mash-up of like yes okay this is pretty much like the trailer it's a
没有。他们有，如果你点击，如果你去他们的网站，你要谈论预告片吗？因为我买这个游戏的原因是因为预告片。哦，真的吗？嗯，我本来想说，如果你点击团队，他们有员工的照片，而且他们很搞笑。好的。但是的，那么预告片呢？哦，真的吗？我本来想说，如果你点击团队，嗯，他们有员工的照片，而且他们很搞笑。好的。但是的，那么预告片呢？所以如果你看预告片，它就像一个混搭，就像，是的，好的，这很像预告片，它是一个
mash-up of like every 80s and 90s video game commercial if there ever like was one like this and it's just like amazing you should definitely watch the trailer if you grew up in the 80s and 90s at least in america and uh i keep giving that caveat i should stop people should just assume that but uh people were making fun of it like this is stupid and it's chintzy and cheesy it's like no i remember all the gi joe commercials that were exactly like that uh growing up and so anyways then i bought it and it was like the comedy is very similar um and you know they break the third wall sometimes or whatever like they talk to you i guess or whatever they make fun of themselves anyway so and the gameplay is nice and it's approachable i'll say that that means easy enough for me to do well at but uh okay
混搭，就像每一个 80 年代和 90 年代的电子游戏广告，如果曾经有过像这样的，它简直太棒了，如果你在 80 年代和 90 年代长大，至少在美国，你绝对应该看预告片，嗯，我一直给出那个警告，我应该停止，人们应该只是假设，但嗯，人们在取笑它，就像这很愚蠢，而且它很廉价，很俗气，就像不，我记得所有完全像那样的特种部队广告，嗯，长大，所以无论如何，然后我买了它，它就像喜剧非常相似，嗯，你知道，他们有时会打破第三面墙什么的，就像他们和你说话，我猜，或者无论如何，他们取笑自己，无论如何，所以游戏玩法很好，而且很容易接近，我会说这意味着对我来说足够容易做得好，但嗯，好的
so it's approachable, and I like it. And I've been playing it. I haven't beat it yet, but I think I'm pretty close to the end. So check it out, Skulls of the Shogun, if you like strategy games and don't want to be humiliated. How much does it cost? Do you remember? I think it's like $5. Okay.
所以它很容易接近，我喜欢它。我一直在玩它。我还没通关，但我认为我快到结尾了。所以去看看吧，《幕府将军的头骨》，如果你喜欢策略游戏并且不想被羞辱的话。它要多少钱？你记得吗？我想大约 5 美元。好的。
That's not bad. I mean, I play it on my iPad, and it's beautiful. It's nice nice and i've gotten so many hours out of it i had to spend a lot of time at jury duty and uh i definitely was playing this when when i wasn't not supposed to be doing anything yeah you're just like every now and then you look up from your ipad guilty no no when the judge told us we couldn't no i i put it all away uh but all the rest of the time, there's a lot of downtime at court. I see.
那还不错。我的意思是，我在我的 iPad 上玩它，它很漂亮。它很好，很好，我从中得到了很多小时，我不得不在陪审团服务上花很多时间，嗯，当我不需要做任何事情时，我绝对在玩这个，是的，你就像时不时地从你的 iPad 上抬头，有罪，不，不，当法官告诉我们我们不能时，不，我把所有东西都收起来了，嗯，但剩下的所有时间，法庭上有很多停机时间。我明白了。
Yeah, I was definitely playing it. We should definitely do a show on jury duty. I can go on at length about that. Okay. This is awesome. It's $4.99. I will definitely buy this immediately. But don't tell me that it was too easy because then I'll be embarrassed.
是的，我绝对在玩它。我们绝对应该做一个关于陪审团服务的节目。我可以详细谈谈那个。好的。这太棒了。它是 4.99 美元。我绝对会立即购买这个。但不要告诉我它太容易了，因为那样我会很尴尬。
No, I'm just like you. I mean, I love love strategy games and i'm equally terrible at all of them so uh this is it sounds right at my eye all right all right so open scad that's right uh so open is that like a open wound like open an open scab so so we'll talk a little bit about like 3d modeling 3d models in general so this is a programming language used for creating 3d models and 3d models are interesting because there's lots of ways to create them you can create them with what's called computer-aided design tools cad which are things like SolidWorks, or I guess even things like Maya or Blender or other things where you create shapes
不，我跟你一样。我的意思是，我喜欢，喜欢策略游戏，而且我对所有这些游戏都同样糟糕，所以嗯，这听起来正合我意，好的，好的，所以 OpenScad，没错，嗯，所以 Open 是像开放性伤口一样，像打开一个开放的痂，所以我们将谈论一点关于 3D 建模，3D 模型，总的来说，所以这是一种用于创建 3D 模型的编程语言，3D 模型很有趣，因为有很多方法可以创建它们，你可以用所谓的计算机辅助设计工具 CAD 来创建它们，比如 SolidWorks，或者我猜甚至是像 Maya 或 Blender 或其他东西，在那里你创建形状
and you shift them and move them interactively with your mouse. But we're programmers, that's boring and hard and artistic. And we're none of those things, I'm none of those things. So OpenScad is a programming language to create the same kinds of things, these 3D models. And 3D models, ultimately, you're trying to represent some shape or object or thing you want to build or make
并且你交互式地用鼠标移动它们。但我们是程序员，这很无聊，很难，而且很艺术。我们都不是那些东西，我不是那些东西。所以 OpenScad 是一种编程语言，用来创建同样的东西，这些 3D 模型。而且 3D 模型，最终，你试图代表你想要构建或制作的某种形状或物体或东西
or use in a video game. And you're trying to make some abstract representation of what we'll call the real world. And one of the interesting things i like about the languages that try to describe these is that you know they can be really pure um so if you have a sphere in the real life in real world no perfect sphere exists right so like in the real world you've never encountered one because it would have to be perfectly smooth and have perfect roundness. And ultimately you can't because they're made of molecules and the molecules have
或在电子游戏中使用的东西。而且你试图对我们所说的现实世界做出某种抽象的表示。而且我喜欢试图描述这些的语言的有趣之处之一是，你知道它们可以非常纯粹，嗯，所以如果你在现实生活中有一个球体，在现实世界中没有完美的球体存在，对吧？所以就像在现实世界中你从来没有遇到过一个，因为它必须是完美的平滑并且有完美的圆度。而且最终你不能，因为它们是由分子组成的，而分子有
size and shape. And so you'll never have something which is a perfect sphere. Somebody's going to correct me with some example of something that's a perfect sphere, but it's okay. That would be hard to do. I think you're in the right here. Okay. All right. It sounds good. All right. all right good so but like in this language you can you can represent something that's a perfect sphere right that has is very uniform and and and smooth uh and then you can do things with it like take another sphere and join the two together and make a two sphere thing and if you build up shapes um you begin to come up with complex objects or you know uh shift shapes around. And we'll talk about more specifics of that later. But I always, I'm terrible at drawing.
大小和形状。所以你永远不会有完美的球体。有人会用完美的球体的例子来纠正我，但这没关系。那很难做到。我想你是对的。好的。好的。听起来不错。好的。好的，很好，所以但在这种语言中，你可以代表一个完美的球体，对吧？它非常均匀且平滑，嗯，然后你可以用它做一些事情，比如拿另一个球体并将两者连接在一起，做一个双球体的东西，如果你构建形状，嗯，你开始想出复杂的物体，或者你知道，移动形状。我们稍后会谈论更多细节。但我总是，我不擅长绘画。
I think Jason does drawing. So maybe he can tell us more about this. Definitely. I've done a lot of Blender, but OpenSCAD is new to me. So drawing, you know, like always, like when I try to read like how to draw, and they're always like, start by breaking down the scene into shapes.
我想杰森会画画。所以也许他能告诉我们更多关于这个的信息。当然。我做过很多 Blender，但 OpenSCAD 对我来说是新的。所以绘画，你知道，就像总是，就像当我试图读如何画画时，他们总是说，从把场景分解成形状开始。
So like you have a head and a head is a circle and the ears are squished circles and ovals um and stuff like this and they always like show the you draw these like square and a couple lines and some circles and then like two steps later you have like a perfectly drawn guy riding a horse it's like there's always that one step like it's like okay i see it i see it and then they're like now fill in the details and that those are like the four or five words of death like when you see in any art instruction book now fill in the details the details include like going to college getting a degree in art and coming back and finishing the try yeah i'm not sure that's true but yeah so i mean but this open scad these things that represent uh trying to make 3d models from basic shapes and
所以就像你有一个头，头是一个圆圈，耳朵是压扁的圆圈和椭圆，嗯，之类的东西，他们总是像展示你画这些，像正方形和几条线和一些圆圈，然后就像两步之后你有一个完美画出的骑马的人，就像总是有那一步，就像好的，我看到了，我看到了，然后他们就像现在填补细节，而那些就像死亡的四五个词，当你在任何艺术指导书中看到时，现在填补细节，细节包括像上大学，获得艺术学位，然后回来完成尝试，是的，我不确定那是真的，但是的，所以我的意思是，但这个 OpenScad，这些代表试图从基本形状制作 3D 模型的东西和
operations it kind of to me represents the same thing like i if i'm trying to build a model of my kitchen table at first i'd say oh okay it's just a rectangular prism and four rectangular prisms for legs but no table really looks like that looks boring uh and terrible so then you have to like chamfer the corners like put a little round over on them um you need like a little bead detail around the bottom and there's like an apron around underneath the tabletop and there's like an inlay right and you begin to but all those things are also simple and so like if i can simply build up to the object i'm trying to represent to me i feel like that's an easier approach than when i've tried to do like the modeling and for some reason it doesn't work for me yeah i mean the other thing too right is like blender and maya and these tools like zbrush and so on you know they're meant to be
操作，对我来说，它代表了同样的事情，就像如果我试图构建我的厨房桌子的模型，起初我会说，哦，好的，它只是一个长方体和四个长方体作为腿，但没有桌子看起来真的是那样，看起来很无聊，而且很糟糕，所以你必须像倒角角落，在它们上面做一个小圆角，你需要像底部周围有一个小珠子细节，桌子下面有一个围裙，还有一个镶嵌，对吧，你开始，但所有这些东西也很简单，所以就像如果我可以简单地构建到我试图代表的物体，对我来说，我觉得这比我尝试做建模时更容易，而且出于某种原因它对我不起作用，是的，我的意思是另一件事，对吧，就像 Blender 和 Maya 以及这些工具，比如 ZBrush 等等，你知道它们旨在成为
like creative tools by artists who want to draw like most of the time you know cartoony non-photorealistic things right and they don't work very well if you need to build something precise like a table that shouldn't wobble right no that's a good point yeah so organic right like exactly an animal would be hard to like draw a perfect representation of using ovals and shapes exactly sort of introducing some sort of randomness right but the opposite is also true where like like, you know, in Blender and these tools, it's not really designed for precision. And so you're kind of expected that if you draw like a bear, that the four legs aren't going to touch the ground in exactly the same spot.
像艺术家想要画的创意工具，大多数时候，你知道，卡通的非照片级真实感的东西，对吧，而且如果你需要构建精确的东西，比如不应该摇晃的桌子，它们工作得不太好，对吧？不，这是一个很好的观点，是的，所以有机，对吧，就像完全一样，动物很难用椭圆和形状画出完美的表示，完全是引入某种随机性，对吧，但反之亦然，就像，你知道，在 Blender 和这些工具中，它并不是真正为精度设计的。所以你有点被期望，如果你画一只熊，四条腿不会完全在同一个地方接触地面。
You know, you're probably using, you know, like a tablet, a Wacom or something. And, you know, it's, I'm sure if you zoomed in really closely on, you know, any model in, you know, World of Warcraft or any of these games that, you know, the legs wouldn't all line up perfectly and things like that. Or an intern was there trying to get them all to align. Yeah, that's right. But, but, you know, if you, you know, built a table that way and then actually had it printed and then, you know, got the table back, you'd be very disappointed. So OpenScout really excels in this area where you need precision. Yeah. So another way that people use are NURBS.
你知道，你可能正在使用，你知道，像平板电脑，Wacom 或其他东西。而且，你知道，我敢肯定，如果你非常仔细地放大，你知道，魔兽世界或任何这些游戏中的任何模型，你知道，腿不会完全对齐，诸如此类的事情。或者一个实习生在那里试图让他们全部对齐。是的，那是对的。但是，但是，你知道，如果你那样建造了一张桌子，然后实际打印出来，然后，你知道，拿回了桌子，你会非常失望。所以 OpenScout 在你需要精度的领域确实表现出色。是的。所以人们使用的另一种方式是 NURBS。
What are NURBS? NURBS. So, right. So there's... You know it's going to be good when there's a wind up before the pitch yeah that's right so most 3D modeling
什么是 NURBS？NURBS。所以，没错。所以有……你知道当投球前有风时它会很好，是的，那是对的，所以大多数 3D 建模
is done through polygons right so this is essentially triangles just a triangle or triangles well yeah Blender actually has n gons support um and then but i'm assuming yeah before it goes to your graphics card it gets turned into polygons um or sorry to triangles but
是通过多边形完成的，对吧？所以这本质上是三角形，只是一个三角形或三角形，嗯，是的，Blender 实际上有 N 边形支持，嗯，然后，但我假设，是的，在它进入你的显卡之前，它变成了多边形，或者抱歉，变成了三角形，但
uh but you know usually you know most of these models are done by taking you know say triangles and and and putting a bunch of them together, right? But there's also this other way, and it's kind of like, you know how like you can use Photoshop, and at the end of the day, you're drawing pixels. You know, like you might draw a line or a circle in Photoshop, but it's really just, you know, a bunch of pixels. And Photoshop is clever enough to take the concept of a circle and the equations that define a circle
嗯，但你知道，通常，你知道，大多数这些模型是通过采取，你知道，比如三角形，并将它们中的一堆放在一起完成的，对吧？但还有另一种方式，它有点像，你知道就像你可以使用 Photoshop，而在一天结束时，你正在画像素。你知道，就像你可能在 Photoshop 中画一条线或一个圆圈，但它实际上只是一堆像素。而且 Photoshop 足够聪明，可以采用圆圈的概念和定义圆圈的方程
and turn it into a bunch of black and white dots, right? But then you also have, you know, vector art like Illustrator, right? Where it actually stores the equation of a circle and then at runtime, you know, anytime you do anything to that circle, you know, on the fly, it's turning the equation of a circle and then at runtime you know anytime you do anything to that circle you know on the fly it's turning the equation of the circle into pixels so nerbs takes that idea and extends it to 3d so a nerbs it stands for non-uniform rational b-spline oh so enlightening and uh
并将它变成一堆黑白点，对吧？但然后你也有，你知道，矢量艺术，比如 Illustrator，对吧？它实际上存储了圆圈的方程，然后在运行时，你知道，任何时候你对那个圆圈做任何事情，你知道，在飞行中，它正在转动圆圈的方程，然后在运行时，你知道，任何时候你对那个圆圈做任何事情，你知道，在飞行中，它正在转动圆圈的方程变成像素，所以 nerbs 采取了这个想法并将其扩展到 3D，所以 nerbs 它代表非均匀有理 B 样条，哦，如此启发，嗯
basically what it is is just in the same way, it's a mathematical explanation of a curve or a sphere or a torus or what have you. And it can define arbitrarily complex shapes using these splines that are connected together
基本上它是什么，只是以同样的方式，它是曲线或球体或圆环或你有什么的数学解释。而且它可以定义任意复杂的形状，使用这些连接在一起的样条
through control points. But then again, it's not a bunch of triangles it's this equation that then you can resolve into triangles anytime you want so open scad has you start with some shape we talked about this but you can have like a 2d shape a 3d shape and if you start with a 2d shape you typically i don't the terminal extrude it you kind of like stretch it in some way or some fashion some transformation um so if you take a square and you move orthogonal to the plane the square is in up you make a cube well or some
通过控制点。但话说回来，它不是一堆三角形，它是这个方程，然后你可以在任何时候解析成三角形，所以 open scad 让你从某种形状开始，我们谈到了这个，但你可以有像 2D 形状，3D 形状，如果你从 2D 形状开始，你通常，我不，终端挤压它，你有点像以某种方式或某种方式拉伸它，某种转换，所以如果你拿一个正方形并移动正交于正方形所在的平面，向上，你做一个立方体，嗯，或者一些
rectangular prism i guess um and you can stretch it but if you move the square through like a curve you get a curvy shape or a circle through a curve you get like a pipe or a tube um so you can start with 2d shapes because the 3d shapes are often you know start as 2d shapes um or 3d and they have you know primitive shapes so they have circle square um you know they have primitive shapes. So they have circle, square. They have primitive 3D shapes. So you have things like sphere and cylinder, polyhedron. And these are your basic building blocks. And then when you combine them with the translations like we talked about then you can move them shift them around stretch them and transformations could be like um scale it like
长方体，我猜，嗯，你可以拉伸它，但如果你通过像曲线移动正方形，你得到一个弯曲的形状，或者通过曲线移动圆圈，你得到像管道或管子，所以你可以从 2D 形状开始，因为 3D 形状通常，你知道，从 2D 形状开始，嗯，或者 3D，它们有，你知道，原始形状，所以它们有圆圈，正方形，嗯，你知道，它们有原始形状。所以它们有圆圈，正方形。它们有原始 3D 形状。所以你有像球体和圆柱体，多面体这样的东西。这些是你的基本构建块。然后当你把它们与我们谈到的转换结合起来时，你就可以移动它们，移动它们，拉伸它们，转换可以是像，嗯，缩放它，像
make it bigger um or rotate it like spin it around translate it move it move it side to side and these are the kind of things that the transformations uh and when you combine them and we'll talk a little come back to transformations in a second you combine them with like boolean operations so if i have like one circle another circle and i union them together i join them together or let's say three i have three circles and i join them together just so you can make a snowman you know with three circles three are three spheres sorry more circles yeah right joined on top of each other or if i difference uh you know to one sphere from another sphere i can take a bite out of the sphere or you know
把它变大，嗯，或者旋转它，像旋转它，平移它，移动它，左右移动它，这些是转换的那种东西，嗯，当你结合它们时，我们稍后会回到转换，你把它们与像布尔运算结合起来，所以如果我有像一个圆圈，另一个圆圈，我把它们联合在一起，我把它们连接在一起，或者假设三个，我有三个圆圈，我把它们连接在一起，这样你就可以做一个雪人，你知道，有三个圆圈，三个是三个球体，抱歉，更多的圆圈，是的，没错，连接在彼此之上，或者如果我差异，嗯，你知道，从一个球体中减去一个球体，我可以从球体中咬一口，或者你知道
a square to a sphere you can start to build up with these basic boolean operations and the shapes and the transformations you can start to build up very complex shapes and there are different kinds of transformations like we talked about and uh just like basic ones like scale and rotate shift slide um but then there are more complex ones it's like a fine transformation so what is an a fine transformation right so an a fine transformation is a 2d transformation and i I think, let me look it up. There's some like math property that makes it. Okay, so these ones that where you can describe by a matrix multiply?
一个正方形到一个球体，你可以开始用这些基本的布尔运算和形状和转换来构建，你可以开始构建非常复杂的形状，并且有不同种类的转换，就像我们谈到的，嗯，只是像基本的，像缩放和旋转，移动，滑动，嗯，但然后有更复杂的，它就像一个仿射转换，所以什么是仿射转换，对吧？所以一个仿射转换是一个 2D 转换，我，我想，让我查一下。有一些像数学属性使它。好的，所以这些你可以通过矩阵乘法描述的？
Oh, that's right. So an affine transformation is one that it preserves points, straight lines, and planes. So the idea is like, you know, if you have n points and you do the transformation, then you have endpoints. You know, it doesn't like collapse the space or anything like that. And if a line is straight as a result of transformation, the line will still be straight. So it won't be, there won't be any kind of like weird, like radial warping or anything like that. So most transformations are either affine transformations or either, you know, translations.
哦，没错。仿射变换是一种保持点、直线和平面的变换。所以它的概念是，你知道，如果你有 n 个点，进行变换后，你仍然有 n 个点。它不会像坍缩空间之类的。如果一条线在变换前是直的，变换后它依然是直的。所以不会出现任何奇怪的径向扭曲之类的东西。大多数变换要么是仿射变换，要么是平移。
So like you move something, you slide it. Rotations rotations so you kind of rotate it around some pivot point or you know kind of sheer operations like scaling or just scaling in one dimension or things like that and it turns out that most of what you need to do like if you have several basic primitives like squares rectangles things like that and you have access to affine transformations that you can create, you know, just about anything. Then there's, yeah, there's 3D transformations like the Euler transformations. If you've ever done anything with like control theory, like with gimbals or you know controlling like a arm for a robot or something like that you could think of sort of even like if you move your hand around you can kind of like twist your hand right but then you can kind of move your hand from side to side like if you were waving but your
比如你移动某物，滑动它。旋转，就是绕着某个枢轴点旋转，或者像缩放这样的剪切操作，或者仅在一个维度上进行缩放等等。事实证明，如果你有几个基本图元，比如正方形、矩形之类的，并且可以使用仿射变换，那么你几乎可以创建任何东西。然后，还有 3D 变换，比如欧拉变换。如果你曾经做过控制理论方面的工作，比如使用万向节，或者控制机器人手臂之类的，你可以想象一下，即使你移动你的手，你可以扭转你的手，对吧？但你也可以左右移动你的手，就像你在挥手，但你的
wrist was locked right you could kind of just wave your hand or you can move your hand kind of up and down like if you go to like grab your mouse you kind of like tilt your hand down so this is like the three axes which you can move your arm and so you can do like Euler 3d transformations where you specify these axes they're called roll pitch and yaw but then you end up in these it just if you follow the math it kind of breaks down and you can end up in what's called gimbal lock um can you do you want to describe gimbal lock you probably know more about it than i do actually i don't think i do this is where you get to a
手腕是锁定的，对吧？你可以挥手，或者你可以上下移动你的手，就像你去抓鼠标时，你会向下倾斜你的手。这就是你可以移动手臂的三个轴，所以你可以进行欧拉 3D 变换，指定这些轴，它们被称为翻滚、俯仰和偏航（roll, pitch, and yaw）。但随后你会陷入这些……如果你遵循数学逻辑，它会崩溃，你最终会陷入所谓的“万向节死锁”。嗯，你想描述一下万向节死锁吗？你可能比我更了解它。其实，我不认为我了解。这就是当你到达一个
a place where you can't represent it correctly yeah i think i think it's a bit good yeah i think gimbal lock is where you can look it up and i'll try to explain it and you can correct me when i'm wrong but i think gimbal lock is where you end up in a situation where doing one of those transformations doesn't change anything like for example um let's say you're looking straight up in the air if you kind of like if you turn your head let me see if I get this right this is a tough thing to explain yeah it is looking so you're looking straight up in the air then oh yeah if you're looking straight up in the air then if you like lean your head from side to side nothing changes if you're looking straight up in the air, then if you lean your head from side to side, nothing changes
无法正确表示它的位置时。是的，我想……我想这有点……是的，我认为万向节死锁是……你可以查一下，我会试着解释，如果我错了你可以纠正我。但我认为万向节死锁是指你陷入了一种情况，即执行其中一种变换不会改变任何东西。例如，嗯，假设你正向上看。如果你……如果你转动你的头，让我看看我是否理解正确，这很难解释。是的，确实很难。所以你正向上看，然后……哦，是的，如果你正向上看，那么如果你左右倾斜你的头，什么都不会改变。如果你正向上看，那么如果你左右倾斜你的头，什么都不会改变。
because you're already straight up in the air. Something like that. You can be in a position where if you put one of the axes in a certain way, you can make it so one of the three axes is a no-op. And the reason why this is a problem is because the value of that axis like doesn't matter it's undefined and that causes chaos like like that value can oscillate wildly and the picture won't change um so so like the system is stable even though that value can be anything and it causes just complete chaos in control theory so did i get that right yeah yeah
因为你已经正对着上方了。类似那样。你可能处于这样一种位置：如果你以某种方式设置其中一个轴，你可以使三个轴中的一个失效。之所以这是一个问题，是因为该轴的值无关紧要，它是未定义的，这会导致混乱。比如，那个值可以剧烈波动，而画面却不会改变。嗯，所以系统是稳定的，即使那个值可以是任何东西，这在控制理论中会导致彻底的混乱。我理解对了吗？是的，是的。
pretty good so basically yeah like some place where you yeah you lose one of your degrees of freedom and it causes mathematical and it happened in apollo 11 so on apollo 11 yeah they had a problem where they got into an orientation near 85 degrees of pitch, uh, that the, the stabilization loop got messed up. Um,
相当不错。基本上，是的，就像某个地方你失去了其中一个自由度，它会导致数学上的……这在阿波罗 11 号上发生过。所以在阿波罗 11 号上，是的，他们遇到了一个问题，当姿态接近 85 度俯仰角时，稳定回路出了问题。嗯，
and so they were supposed to like, like it was supposed to, the gimbal was supposed to like flip around at that time or whatever. But, um, it, for some reason it got messed up and froze. Uh,
所以他们本应该……本应该……万向节本应该在那时翻转之类的。但是，嗯，由于某种原因它出了故障并冻结了。嗯，
and so they had to manually like move, move it or whatever. Oh, and then realign it so yeah it actually was a big problem but yeah okay we're yeah so you can imagine like if in general right like if a number can be anything and on the outside it doesn't
所以他们不得不手动移动它之类的。哦，然后重新对齐它。所以是的，这确实是一个大问题。但好吧，我们……是的，所以你可以想象，通常情况下，如果一个数字可以是任何值，而在外部它又
matter then over time that number will just assume any value and then what happens is eventually things change in the system and all of a sudden that number matters but it's four billion and it just the system just doesn't know what to do with four billion it just collapses so so they came up with this idea of quaternions and again this is really hard to explain i'm not going to do it justice. But basically, the idea is you assume that there's a fourth dimension. Yeah.
无关紧要，那么随着时间的推移，那个数字就会变成任何值。然后发生的情况是，最终系统中的某些东西发生了变化，突然间那个数字变得很重要了，但它是 40 亿，系统根本不知道如何处理 40 亿，它就崩溃了。所以他们提出了四元数的概念。同样，这真的很难解释，我无法把它讲透。但基本上，这个想法是你假设存在第四个维度。是的。
And you do all of your math assuming this fourth dimension. And this fourth dimension ends up, you also normalize by the fourth dimension. So in other words, you know, if you have a vector in general, or if you have a list of numbers in general, you can do this thing called normalizing, where the biggest number becomes one, and all the other numbers become some fraction of the biggest number, right? So like, you talk about like normalizing people's grades,
然后你所有的数学计算都假设这个第四维度的存在。这个第四维度最终……你还要根据第四维度进行归一化。换句话说，你知道，如果你有一个通用的向量，或者一个通用的数字列表，你可以做一种叫做归一化的事情，其中最大的数字变成 1，所有其他数字变成最大数字的分数，对吧？就像你谈论归一化人们的成绩，
or like, you know, grading on the curve or something like that. Right. When you grade on the curve, what you're doing, you're taking the highest person. Let's say he got an 80. So that means everyone else's grade is over 80. And that guy who got an 80, he gets 100 percent. Right. So you have this fourth dimension that doesn't really exist. You can't visualize it it but it's there for all the calculations and you're constantly normalizing by all four of the dimensions and so it keeps even when you have gimbal lock in the three dimensions the fourth dimension
或者像按曲线评分之类的。对。当你按曲线评分时，你所做的是，你取最高分的人。假设他得了 80 分。这意味着其他人的成绩都是除以 80。而那个得 80 分的人，他得到 100%。对吧？所以你有这个并不真正存在的第四维度。你无法将其可视化，但它存在于所有的计算中，并且你不断地根据所有四个维度进行归一化，所以即使在三个维度中出现万向节死锁时，第四维度
keeps everything from going crazy that's uh that's the best way i can explain it. A little bit of 3D theory to warm your soul. Yeah, that's right. So another advantage of OpenSCAD over other modeling programs is that you can define stuff as basically a formula, right? So like the height is two times the width. And then somebody can simply define how high they want the thing to be and it automatically generates it at the appropriate width. Oh, that's cool.
也能防止一切变得疯狂。这是我能解释的最好的方式了。一点 3D 理论来温暖你的灵魂。是的，没错。所以 OpenSCAD 相比其他建模程序的另一个优势是，你可以基本上把东西定义为一个公式，对吧？比如高度是宽度的两倍。然后某人可以简单地定义他们想要的高度，它就会自动以适当的宽度生成它。哦，那很酷。
Yeah, so for, like, 3D printing, this is pretty cool, right? So typically you might be able to scale something, right? So, like, you have a model of Jason's head, and you're going to 3D print it. And you can apply a basic scale, which just says all the points in the 3D model, like, expand them the same amount from origin or whatever and then you get a accurate representation of a bigger jason's head but what if you had things that uh you know wanted to move in relation to one another and so you had like gears and if you scale the gears maybe the meshing of the gears changes
是的，所以对于 3D 打印来说，这很酷，对吧？通常你可能能够缩放某物，对吧？比如，你有一个 Jason 头部的模型，你要 3D 打印它。你可以应用一个基本的缩放，它只是说 3D 模型中的所有点，比如，从原点或其他地方以相同的量扩展它们，然后你就得到了一个更大的 Jason 头部的精确表示。但如果你有一些东西……你知道，想要相对于彼此移动，比如你有齿轮，如果你缩放齿轮，也许齿轮的啮合就会改变。
oh right and so you can end up with with complexing or you only want to scale you know in one dimension but you want the all the gears to stay you know the gears need to can't be scaled in one dimension right like they have to be round they have to be a perfect circle close to a perfect circle um and so you if you wanted to scale the thing in one dimension, you would need to do something else. And so parameterizing allows you to handle these kinds of things. Oh, that's amazing.
哦，对。所以你最终可能会遇到复杂的情况，或者你只想在一个维度上缩放，但你希望所有的齿轮保持……你知道，齿轮不能在一个维度上缩放，对吧？它们必须是圆的，它们必须是一个完美的圆，接近完美的圆。嗯，所以如果你想在一个维度上缩放物体，你需要做别的事情。所以参数化允许你处理这些类型的事情。哦，那太棒了。
There's also a tool really similar to OpenScad called ImplicitCAD, which is written in Haskell, which is cool. And it's actually one of the few commonly used things that I could think of that was written in Haskell yeah right not that that's a knock against Haskell sometimes people say like oh what's written in that language
还有一个和 OpenSCAD 非常相似的工具叫 ImplicitCAD，它是用 Haskell 编写的，这很酷。而且它实际上是我能想到的为数不多的常用且用 Haskell 编写的东西之一。是的，没错。并不是说这是对 Haskell 的批评，有时人们会说，哦，那是什么语言写的？
well this is written ImplicitCAD is written in Haskell and is very similar to OpenSCAD so is OpenSCAD a tool or a language or both oh okay gotcha so the language itself though like and apparently i wasn't the only one like i saw other people saying the same thing immediately made me remember when i was in college and doing ray tracing so always like i took a
嗯，这是用 Haskell 编写的，ImplicitCAD 是用 Haskell 编写的，而且和 OpenSCAD 非常相似。那么 OpenSCAD 是一个工具、一种语言还是两者都是？哦，好的，明白了。不过语言本身……显然我不是唯一一个这样想的人，我看到其他人也说了同样的话，这立刻让我想起了我在大学做光线追踪的时候。所以我总是……我上了一门
computer graphics class and it's very classical like you have to learn about lighting and about ray tracing. The most common, or one of the most common ray tracers that people use is POV ray. And they have a scene description language where it's the same thing. You describe objects and then you make a picture that represents what the scene would look like from a specific point of view.
计算机图形学课，它非常经典，你必须学习光照和光线追踪。人们使用的最常见的光线追踪器之一是 POV-Ray。他们有一种场景描述语言，是一样的东西。你描述物体，然后制作一张图片，代表从特定视角看场景的样子。
So the only thing additional from what OpenSCAD does is is you define a camera angle like things that describe the camera basically um and lighting but aside from that like the objects are just the same they just describe a scene um but you have special things which are light since one special thing i guess which is a camera um and they become very similar after that like you're using basic shapes and primitives and transformations to build up a scene you know yeah that's uh i wonder if like uh i mean is there a lot of open scad content in other words like this is there if i wanted just like a car to 3d print would someone have just made a car in open scad that i could download or something i mean is there yes like on thingiverse like yeah there's a lot of stuff on thingiverse
所以除了 OpenSCAD 所做的之外，唯一额外的东西就是你定义一个摄像机角度，比如基本上描述摄像机的东西，还有光照。但除此之外，物体都是一样的，它们只是描述一个场景。但你有特殊的东西，比如光，我想有一个特殊的东西是摄像机。在那之后它们变得非常相似，就像你使用基本形状、图元和变换来构建一个场景一样。你知道，是的，那……我想知道是否……我的意思是，OpenSCAD 的内容多吗？换句话说，如果我想要一个 3D 打印的汽车，是否有人已经在 OpenSCAD 中制作了一辆我可以下载的汽车之类的？我的意思是，有吗？是的，比如在 Thingiverse 上，是的，Thingiverse 上有很多东西。
oh those are done in open scad not all or they could be some of them yeah yeah gotcha yeah cool cool but yeah for sure sure, like, I mean, typically these things, like, actually, I don't know if OpenSCAD supports it, but I know like POV Ray, like you can import a model. So if you have like a 3D surface mesh, I guess they're called meshes, a mesh, right? Like with a texture, you can import it into the scene.
哦，那些是用 OpenSCAD 做的吗？不是全部，或者它们可能是。其中一些是。是的，是的，明白了。是的，很酷，很酷。但确实，当然，我的意思是，通常这些东西，实际上，我不知道 OpenSCAD 是否支持，但我知道像 POV-Ray，你可以导入一个模型。所以如果你有一个 3D 表面网格，我想它们被称为网格，一个网格，对吧？带有纹理，你可以把它导入到场景中。
And hopefully it's, you know, small enough where you can't discern the triangles, but it'll bounce the rays off of it into the scene um and hopefully it's you know small enough where you can't discern the triangles but it'll bounce the rays off of it just the same oh interesting um but also yeah i'm on the i'm on the thingiverse site where you can download um you know open scad um you know files and uh yeah it's cool they have like iphone cases have you tried making an iphone case i have not yet okay yeah there's a bunch of really cool things a stacking container yeah definitely go to openscad.com gallery and then i'm assuming that you can just download the uh source code for this yeah yeah and then build it yep so it's very useful for that so like wanting to get started in like 3d printing and like oh
希望它足够小，让你看不出三角形，但它会把光线反射到场景中。嗯，希望它足够小，让你看不出三角形，但它会把光线反射到场景中。哦，有趣。嗯，但我也在 Thingiverse 网站上，你可以下载 OpenSCAD 文件。嗯，是的，很酷，他们有 iPhone 手机壳。你试过制作 iPhone 手机壳吗？我还没有。好的，是的，有一堆非常酷的东西，堆叠容器。是的，一定要去 openscad.com 的画廊，然后我假设你可以直接下载它的源代码。是的，是的，然后构建它。是的，所以它在这方面非常有用。所以就像想要开始 3D 打印，比如“哦，
i want to be able to make my own models uh to 3d print but i don't want to have to learn a modeling program um and so this is what i came across and so this is this is my the endeavor i'm embarking upon okay all right do you have a 3d printer or no no but i have access to 3d printers oh i see ha ha ha that's ambiguous and uh mysterious i know a guy i know a guy i know a guy who knows a guy no no i just know the guy oh okay you have so one degree of freedom between you and the guy who has a 3d printer? And only one more between him and Kevin Bacon. Okay. How much between him and Canadian Bacon?
我想能够制作我自己的模型来 3D 打印，但我不想学习建模程序”，这就是我遇到的，所以这就是我正在进行的尝试。好的，好的。你有 3D 打印机吗？没有，但我可以使用 3D 打印机。哦，我明白了。哈哈，这很模棱两可，而且很神秘。我认识一个人，我认识一个人，我认识一个认识有 3D 打印机的人的人。不，不，我只是认识那个人。哦，好的，你和你认识的那个有 3D 打印机的人之间只有一个自由度？他和凯文·贝肯之间也只有一个。好的。他和加拿大培根之间有多少？
Wait, I eat Canadian Bacon, so zero. Oh my gosh. My mind just exploded. There's a 3D printer on Amazon, and it sells for $1,200, but it's on sale for $1,199.
等等，我吃加拿大培根，所以是零。天哪。我的大脑刚刚爆炸了。亚马逊上有一台 3D 打印机，售价 1200 美元，但打折后是 1199 美元。
You save a penny. So Jason's 3D printer shopping right now. Yeah. Hopefully his wife doesn't walk in the room. Yeah, right. You can use OpenSCAD and a 3D printer to obviously print your own things. I was kind of hoping that I could say something nice about the price, but it's actually pretty darn expensive.
你省了一分钱。所以 Jason 现在正在选购 3D 打印机。是的。希望他妻子不要走进房间。是的，没错。你可以使用 OpenSCAD 和 3D 打印机来打印你自己的东西。我本来希望我能对价格说点好话，但它实际上确实非常昂贵。
There's cheaper 3D printer kits. Oh, I see. So, yeah, it's totally expensive. The MakerBot is $2,200. There's this FlashForge that's $1,200. Oh, actually, they do go down. There's one that's 900 yeah so you get them yeah like i've seen them you know like 400 500 for like this one called printer bot without the e
有更便宜的 3D 打印机套件。哦，我明白了。所以，是的，它确实很贵。MakerBot 要 2200 美元。有一个 FlashForge 要 1200 美元。哦，实际上，它们确实会降价。有一个是 900 美元。是的，所以你可以买到它们。是的，就像我见过的那样，你知道，400、500 美元，比如这个叫 PrinterBot 的，没有 e。
okay anyways yeah so they have cheaper ones um and they're coming down all the time and one of the cool things is there are 3d printers designed in OpenSCAD. Oh, nice. So you could get... And it's cool because it kind of works in with the whole bootstrapping thing, like self-rep-wrap is about this self-replicating. And so you write a description in OpenSCAD, and if you have any way of making the shapes
好的，无论如何，是的，所以他们有更便宜的。嗯，而且它们的价格一直在下降。其中一件很酷的事情是，有一些 3D 打印机是用 OpenSCAD 设计的。哦，不错。所以你可以得到……而且这很酷，因为它有点像整个引导程序一样工作，比如 self-rep-wrap 就是关于这种自我复制的。所以你在 OpenSCAD 中写一个描述，如果你有任何方法来制作这些形状，
that are described in OpenSCAD parametrically of whatever size you want, then you make the first one, and then you have a 3D printer, of which you could print more. But of course, there are typically some things which aren't printable that are used. Gotcha.
这些形状在 OpenSCAD 中是参数化描述的，无论你想要什么尺寸，那么你制作第一个，然后你就拥有了一台 3D 打印机，你可以用它打印更多。但当然，通常有一些不可打印的东西被使用。明白了。
Oh, yeah, like I'm sure the metal... It's like metal rods and circuit boards. One day, the idea is that they will be printable, but for now, they aren't. Right, right. But yeah, it's kind of a cool community, and there's a lot of like, it's almost like writing a compiler
哦，是的，就像我确信金属……就像金属棒和电路板。有一天，这个想法是它们将是可打印的，但目前还不是。对，对。但是的，这是一个很酷的社区，而且有很多……这几乎就像编写一个编译器
to compile your compiler. Yeah. No, this is totally awesome. I would love to, I did a little bit of 3D printing, but I need to get back into it. It's a lot of fun. Yeah, so it's still a little pricey, but now that you know OpenSCAD,
来编译你的编译器。是的。不，这太棒了。我很想……我做过一点 3D 打印，但我需要重新开始。这很有趣。是的，所以它仍然有点贵，但既然你现在了解了 OpenSCAD，
at least you have one part that can no longer be an excuse. That's right. Well, I know the guy who knows the guy who has a 3D printer. I will disavow all knowledge of you after this. So you no longer know me. All right. Oh, man. Cool.
至少你有一个部分不再是借口了。没错。好吧，我认识那个认识有 3D 打印机的人的人。在这之后，我将否认所有关于你的认识。所以你不再认识我了。好吧。哦，天哪。酷。
This is awesome. Yeah, I think I would... Actually, one more thing about OpenSCAD, like, does it give you any visual? Because, I mean, I would imagine that, like, this language... Yeah, yeah. You need constant feedback, right? Otherwise, it's hard to do anything.
这太棒了。是的，我想我会……实际上，关于 OpenSCAD 还有一件事，它给你任何视觉效果吗？因为，我的意思是，我会想象，像，这种语言……是的，是的。你需要持续的反馈，对吧？否则很难做任何事情。
Yeah, so there is. There's rendering options, yep. Oh, I see. So, like, while you're coding, you can you can see the object yeah so it's very similar I mean don't my impressions of it using this is very similar to kind of the way if you've ever done ray tracing it's very similar so you kind of edit your code and you kind of have like you click a little button and you know or even interactively it'll show you kind of like the updates you're making can't remember um okay but yeah so um similar yeah when you go to actually make the thing
是的，所以有。有渲染选项，是的。哦，我明白了。所以，就像你在编码时，你可以看到物体。是的，所以它非常相似。我的意思是，我使用它的印象是，它非常类似于如果你曾经做过光线追踪的方式。所以你编辑你的代码，然后你点击一个小按钮，你知道，或者甚至是交互式的，它会向你展示你所做的更新。记不清了……嗯，好的，但是的，所以……相似。是的，当你去真正制作那个东西
or generate some other representation of it than the raw like mathematical description it may do a more complete because ultimately you're you need to like if you're doing a 3d printer you need to tell the machine the exact coordinates to go to but you can't tell it like make this perfect circle because it can't has only finite resolution right right yep so have you printed anything with open scat or not yet not yet okay you'll have to let us know how it goes i want to hear a post-mortem soon i had to make something i'm proud enough like to make real okay because it's just all digital so it's so easy to just like it's like a portrait of painting it's never complete just keep you should do the iphone case at least you have an iphone case that's just someone else's work i need to make my own iphone case oh yeah you should make uh you should you should
或者生成除原始数学描述之外的其他表示时，它可能会做得更完整，因为最终你需要……如果你在做 3D 打印，你需要告诉机器要去的精确坐标，但你不能告诉它“制作这个完美的圆”，因为它不能，它只有有限的分辨率。对，对。是的，所以你用 OpenSCAD 打印过什么东西吗？还没有。好的，你得让我们知道进展如何。我很快想听到一个事后总结。我必须制作一些我足够自豪的东西，比如制作真实的。好的，因为它全是数字化的，所以很容易就像……就像肖像画一样，它永远不会完成，你只需要继续。你应该至少做那个 iPhone 手机壳，那只是别人的作品。我需要制作我自己的 iPhone 手机壳。哦，是的，你应该制作……你应该……
etch your own design into this iphone case that somebody else already made i will make it from scratch if i did not invent it it is inferior you should make you should make the worst iphone case ever like it protects the parts of the iphone that that don't need like it's just a band around the middle it's like a titanium iphone case the case will not break yeah the phone will shatter the case will not break oh man it's yeah okay this is it's getting too late for jason oh man that's awesome well thank you for all the activities and comments and emails we've been getting from everyone yeah we found out the uh the google plus page has what 300 plus ones no 900 900 900 yes oh oh i'm so sorry i
把你自己的设计蚀刻到别人已经制作好的这个 iPhone 手机壳里。我会从零开始制作它。如果不是我发明的，它就是次品。你应该制作……你应该制作有史以来最糟糕的 iPhone 手机壳，它保护 iPhone 不需要保护的部分。就像中间的一条带子。就像一个钛合金 iPhone 手机壳，手机壳不会坏。是的，手机会粉碎，手机壳不会坏。哦，天哪，这……好吧，这对 Jason 来说太晚了。哦，天哪，那太棒了。好吧，谢谢大家发来的所有活动、评论和电子邮件。是的，我们发现 Google Plus 页面有，多少？300 个 +1？不，900 个。900 个。900 个。是的。哦，哦，我很抱歉，我
thought you were pulling my leg it literally i just looked it up we We have 900 plus ones. Yes. That is absolutely amazing. We, we, uh, we love you guys. I have no idea what it's counting, but 900 plus ones, some sort of aggregation of every, I don't care. 900 is a big number that is not counting page views. I'm sure that that account, I'm sure those are 900 actions and it can't be minutes of our podcast because it's far more than 900 yeah so we definitely we we really appreciate your support um you've been buying our book a week uh a lot of you have been buying the books of the week and keeping up with us or at least clicking on our link and buying other things yeah that's right that keeps the the whole operation up and running the server the the
以为你在开玩笑。字面上，我刚刚查了一下，我们有 900 个 +1。是的。这绝对太棒了。我们……我们……我们爱你们。我不知道它在统计什么，但 900 个 +1，某种对每一个的聚合，我不在乎。900 是一个很大的数字，它不是在统计页面浏览量。我确信那个账户，我确信那是 900 次操作，而且不可能是我们播客的分钟数，因为它远不止 900。是的，所以我们绝对……我们非常感谢你们的支持。嗯，你们一直在买我们每周推荐的书。你们很多人一直在买每周推荐的书，并跟上我们的进度，或者至少点击我们的链接并购买其他东西。是的，没错，这让整个运营保持运转，服务器，那个
terabytes of bandwidth that we consume every month, um, cost a lot of money. And yeah, that's motivation to make shorter podcasts, I guess. Yeah. The next podcast will be on hask. Um, we don't have time to do the rest.
我们每月消耗的 TB 级带宽，花费了很多钱。是的，这是制作更短播客的动力，我想。是的。下一个播客将是关于 Haskell 的。嗯，我们没有时间做剩下的了。
Um, but, uh, we appreciate all of your support and, uh, you know, we definitely look forward to, to doing,
嗯，但是，嗯，我们感谢你们所有的支持，而且，嗯，你知道，我们绝对期待，去做，
to, you know, keeping these podcasts going. They've been a lot of fun for us. So keep writing in with your questions. I really like answering them on G+. Yeah, that's what I'm getting out of this story. We should just have you answer questions for the podcast.
去，你知道，保持这些播客继续下去。它们对我们来说很有趣。所以请继续写信提出你们的问题。我真的很喜欢在 G+ 上回答它们。是的，这就是我从这个故事中得到的。我们应该让你只为播客回答问题。
We should do a mailbag. It's been a while. Oh, no. It'll just be all me. I'll just ask all the things I need to do at work. Jason, will you do this work for me? is my compiler not working all right till next time all right catch you guys later the intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to
我们应该做一个邮件袋。已经有一段时间了。哦，不。那将全是我。我只会问所有我需要在工作中做的事情。Jason，你会为我做这项工作吗？我的编译器是不是坏了？好吧，下次见。好的，回头见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以
remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
重新混合、改编该作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。